honestly man um i'm a little bit nervous
i've never sat down to talk to anybody
like this should i be laying down so i
don't really know how to start this i
guess to start from the beginning yeah
she told me she would break my legs i'm
in the second grade i don't even know
what gangs are no matter what they just
keep deleting me i don't know what to do
i i don't do anything wrong i just keep
getting deleted it's frustrating so
there i am 16 i break out of this bear
hug start sprinting down the street and
i just see cops and my own dad call the
cops on me i'm just uh
[Music]
honestly just talking about this makes
me feel so much better thank you so much
well
you certainly do have a lot we can work
on it's really nice meeting you thomas
you're in good hands here we're going to
get you all taken care of thanks for
choosing betterhelp
what's up guys i hope you liked that
little commercial that's from our new
sponsor betterhelp is there something
holding you back is there something in
your brain or a voice telling you i
can't do this i'm not gonna we've all
had that all right maybe we all weren't
brought up the best or maybe just
outside elements just
made us that way i used to be that way
too and this is not just for people with
low self-esteem this is for people with
marriage problems maybe you're in a
horrible relationship maybe you're in a
bad work environment maybe you just want
or need someone to talk to so real quick
guys better help is not a crisis hotline
this is not a suicide prevention hotline
in any way shape or form this is a
licensed professional therapist app in
your phone once you sign up it takes
about 48 hours they because it takes
time to match you with somebody they
can't just be like you know what you
guys would get along that's not how this
works this is worldwide so anybody out
there watching if you need help if you
just need someone to talk to you need to
go check out betterhelp.com if you
cannot afford this there are financial
plans over a million people have
downloaded better help over a million
people have sat and talked to a
therapist over a million people have
taken the first step into a better life
so betterhelp.com
forward slash www.betterhelp.com that's
10 off your first month of treatment so
in conclusion guys some of us need
someone to talk to but too embarrassed
to go to the doctor some of us don't
want everyone to know that they see a
therapist it's not a weak thing
sometimes we just need that person in
our life we just need that outlet
talking about things somehow really
really helps
[Music]
all right here we go what's up guys
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast we are here to talk about life
problems accomplishments drugs and
everything in between today as you guys
can see from the thumbnail we have a
very special episode you guys this is
the trifecta all right that's what i
feel goblin aircon thank you guys so
much for coming today thank you for
flying in thank you for flying back of
course of course we appreciate you guys
thank you for everything thank you for
having us 100 man for everyone
we've been drinking them smoking a
little bit so i know because you guys
both look kind of [ __ ] up already
there's gonna be some more though it's
gonna be somewhere
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah we got we have
time
we have time oh yeah so oh yeah you just
got here from illinois you just flew in
for this again so i appreciate you so
[ __ ] much thank you last time you
here was two months ago yep right i was
only here for a day
last time you flew into flu out cause
your court right yep
champion i had court the next day the
next day he couldn't let's go get out of
it bro
you were here two months ago right yeah
and you were here three months ago yeah
yeah and you just went here for eight it
was eight days you said right i think
something like that it was fresh
just popped in you're now a resident how
do you like it it's dope man there's
just so much more [ __ ] to do like so
much more [ __ ] to do like it's crazy
come out of texas man like i guess
there's some places in texas that are
kind of cool like dallas awesome there's
some there's some cool like i guess
nightlife and everything like that but
in terms of like just cannabis
especially because you know it's just
illegal as [ __ ] out there yeah this is
this is this is the place to be a
hundred percent
so i've been seeing your uh stories and
[ __ ] you've been living it up man it's
been dope it's just been dead it's it's
[ __ ] oh what are you gonna do tonight
oh it's open yeah exactly
what the [ __ ] you're talking about it's
an adult playground out here yeah yeah
it's like a.m and you're like oh we get
some like there's like no food options
and then anywhere in texas like i passed
like midnight or something maybe like
two or three just like whataburger and
[ __ ] you know what i mean everyone just
pops there but then la you have like a
million restaurants that are just 24
hours within like a few miles yeah you
know that's just fired yes it's that's
what i'm saying yeah it's great yes he's
from
from illinois and he was telling me like
there's nothing open past nine
no you literally past nine all you can
get is fast food dude like actual
restaurants clothes hundred percent
you also can't sustain a business if
you're open that lake because you're
only like we got 12 [ __ ] potheads in
the whole town yeah they're not gonna
sustain our bills yeah
yeah you were really gassing up living
out here to me the other day
man it's awesome like it's it's the
place to be especially like you know the
type of work that we're in like yeah
there's no other place
really in the world to be honest with
you right like socal you know what i
mean like l.a capital you know it really
is like it really is like it's crazy
here dude it's the it's the i don't know
the wall street of weed well every time
you come here like this there's way
better than back home like bro every day
you could be doing that yeah i was
talking to him like you know imagine if
you moved out here i know what the cost
of living times three but if you can
triple your profit of your business
you just made double
and you paid your rent yeah and like
lifestyle is like times three like it's
worth it you know what i mean like the
weather you're paying for you're paying
for like the opportunity they're working
you're paying for like all that and it's
like it adds up it's worth it
100 percent yeah 100 more options
think about it about it think about it
i mean i moved from mercy you're in a
town just like mine i had to get the
[ __ ] out of there yeah and you're san
antonio yeah san antonio texas how to
get the [ __ ] out of those places
no one really does like that's the thing
like everyone like it was just like the
natural next step for me like i'm going
to la like it wasn't even like a big
deal like hollywood or whatever the [ __ ]
but like that's how it seems like to
everyone out there they're like oh bro
you like me you're going to like la you
know i'm like yeah it's a small
town that's where i'm like supposed to
be like it's like it's where the weed is
man like that's what i'm supposed to be
100 and they're just like it's just like
a crazy like i guess like culture change
you know what i mean for sure yeah l.a
going to hollywood and [ __ ] right i
never said when i was thinking about la
like there's [ __ ] buildings in
traffic
but after a while you're like yeah bro
it's life yeah accustomed to it right
for sure you know when to drive yeah
definitely yeah all right drive so make
sure your car's low like yeah i can't
even go down that [ __ ] street at all
yeah
that's what i thought and then doing
something right he just
happened that's a heartbreaker
put it right back on nowhere that was
brutal
it should be all right though that's
what i'm saying just like i come screws
i gotta be honest though
we're you know that we're getting
demonetized right away right can we just
spark these joints spend five minutes we
should honestly yeah i think we should
okay okay okay let's do it
i got you guys oh thank you there you go
your light is right there too oh i think
our episode we shared a lighter and an
ashtray huh bro
everyone all the comments right now like
bro get your ashtrays like i didn't
think about it [ __ ] i have a whole
shelf over there of ashtrays i make and
i forgot to put the extra ashtray out
here and right now
there's a plastic one there my bad hey
an ashtrays and ashtray
yeah damn
yo did you guys ever have those homies
that would ash on their pants and then
rub it into their pants oh for sure yeah
it's like yeah
you didn't have a homie that did that
all the time i wouldn't say all the time
i don't know
what it was an ash game unless it really
gets disturbed well when i was younger
there is no like you smoke yours will
smoke my like no full we put in on this
right smoke together
ash on his jeans and just
oh no never did that because it
disappears
yeah i thought you went like people
accidentally ash no no you go like this
you're talking on your jeans and go like
that i don't think i've ever met someone
who ashes on their own you do do right
you've seen it i've seen it before but i
don't know someone who did it
consistently but i've seen it
because when you're in the car and you
have nowhere to ash it disappears and
when you're a dirty [ __ ] skater kid
you don't give a [ __ ] about ashes on
your jeans he's all [ __ ] roughed up
and bleeding from skating
but i don't know i just [ __ ] thought
of that that'd be all bad right now you
guys
all right let's just address the
let's address it
all right
yes it finally happened man sick yeah
yeah
i'm glad
for months everyone's been talking about
for years there's like dude you gotta
get them just gotta link up somewhat and
then the podcast thing happened and i
was like you gotta give me the podcast
because it was like you know you already
discussed linking up right right yeah
when you told me you talked to him right
yeah we planned we were gonna hop boxer
[ __ ] u-haul
stealing them works wait just like the
friends are like
yeah we're gonna just like rent a u-haul
and just like box the [ __ ] out of it
so two years ago i was going to do the
hotboxing u-haul the biggest thing ever
like the biggest hotbox ever and then i
had a firefighter dm me because because
i did a hotbox three ounces in my car
yeah but i was using the lighter
and the [ __ ] firefighter was trying
to plead with me like bro i don't know
how you guys didn't die i don't know
because apparently me letting off that
butane and lighting it and lighting it
with nothing dissipating it's like you
guys should have blew up
i'm surprised your [ __ ] windows
didn't burst oh it's just gas in the air
and you're just like yeah so i told him
about the hot box of the u-haul he goes
please don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
dude the only reason why i didn't i had
to i had to get an opinion from the
firefighter
we would have no advice
[Music]
that's a viral moment bro exploding you
explode two kids exploding in a hot box
like a viral campaign the way you don't
have boxes
[Laughter]
yeah i'm not trying to get hurt for no
views that's why mario was like i'm
talking about bringing mike tyson i'm
like yo
like somehow get him to punch you in the
face like [ __ ] knowing again yeah
that's true you always thought it'd be a
lot of views oh no i said i said what if
it was off-camera thing mike tyson
please don't take this [ __ ] serious
i was like yo marty what if we're doing
an interview with him and like we can do
it i knocked his ass out
like i somehow think and slap him
i would be in the hiding for the rest of
my life
everybody
see
i don't trust that
he's a scary man
but yeah i don't wanna blow up reviews
no no
well i mean but so you guys hotbox idea
that's exactly what i had it all written
out like some [ __ ] skit yeah and i
thought it's gonna be sick and then the
firefighter dm me i went i'm gonna just
back off wow
i don't want to catch him [ __ ] it risk
my life
no if you don't use like butane torch
sliders you're okay you kind of need it
all right
but i was thinking about doing like half
p joints
lighting
everybody like oh you're out get the
[ __ ] out then oh one of those yeah like
before it was cool kind of thing you
know
you're out you can't breathe you have to
get out last person last person wins
like whatever yeah yeah that means you
win nothing but still
you get high that's all it really
matters yeah
hi the most
the highest actually it'd be fun
honestly that would i mean you guys
thought of it too does it sound small
yeah they just sound dope
that sounds fantastic i still want to do
the world's biggest bong i've been
keeping this thing in the corner over
there until i find the other piece
it's lost
no i need to find it because it's not
like a thing that they sell oh oh it's
not i need to find this other piece of
the bong uh-huh their makeshift a giant
[ __ ] bong and my friend told me to
use ice water
[ __ ] smart you know uh the air pumps
people put air pump [ __ ] put that to the
top of it and it would be a filtered
bong okay
you know hot box with filtered ice water
smoke yeah bomb
right that is fun i think
also when you're at uh because i know
you mean you i i'll be posting a video
i'll be uploading oh
damn this one just reviewed this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i did it two days ago
i see that [ __ ] all the time because
i mean we're in california we're working
the same companies yeah
i just think it's [ __ ] hilarious
fools will be like yo you guys are just
sitting there watching each other like
no do you ever think that the company's
just going hey we watch both these guys
yeah yeah do a review but
do you ever get that [ __ ] yeah i get
this [ __ ] all the times yeah oh my god
you're like you're joking you'll be like
bro come on like we're busy for four
days especially
ever since i did the first podcast
episode with you it feels like all the
companies i work with people have been
like oh like
[ __ ] you'll already did that or like
oh yolo must have gave him that and all
that [ __ ] you know really yeah i get a
lot of those comments dicks that's right
it's crazy how the negative comments
just stick i mean there's so little of
them i get like just a few of them but
then you get like 99 like positive
comments you get like those like five
[ __ ] and you just like see it you're
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you yeah no
you're like
try not to address them at all yeah yeah
yeah or i think it was like 2019 i used
to just say you're the coolest guy i've
ever met to anybody that was mean to me
you're the coolest guy i ever met bro
you know what i used to do
i love you
i would i would talk [ __ ] back and then
just like block them so they couldn't
say anything like and just like delete
my comment and delete my comments i know
they got the notification you know what
the new [ __ ] is
you talk
you talk [ __ ] after someone's being
really rude
and then you just restrict their account
so they can't comment back without you
approving and they're sitting there
trying to fight oh
[Laughter]
no don't block them so they can see it
happen and then everybody's like
dancing's not even responding and you
know they're like oh they're going crazy
at home bro
my joint will not stay lit what the [ __ ]
it's all right mine's perfect for sure
dude
i mean i had to realize
the whole time yo so real quick
i can't believe you've never been to
vegas i've never been crazy that's a
problem you just got back from vegas
yeah how was that
oh every time it's like it's a little
episode every time it's like a little
hanging like what's your thing what do
you what do you do you know some people
like oh gamble go here i go here and i
eat here
i don't have a specific like i gamble
for sure and i eat for sure but not at
the same places i kind of like because
i'm like new to whole of vegas because i
just turned 21 last year so i'm trying
to like hit like all the different
casinos and like stay at different
hotels and like eat at the different
restaurants and then that's like kind of
my thing i'm just staying in like
different places all the time but vegas
is dope as [ __ ] like this is like a
little dope playground it's insane
because you're back after covert our
strip clubs even open yeah they are for
sure they're scary
there's some like there's some crazy
ones that you're just like yeah for sure
they'll like walk through and just like
touch your dick and it's like
bro they'll like grab your grope your
[ __ ] and be like come with me baby i'll
be like come on come on like not chill
yeah like come on too
because it like drained the [ __ ] yeti i
mean the first time i was there in vegas
for my 21st birthday
yeah for sure i had a video now i just
had a video of like me going into this
trip that was a funny ass video i just
recorded myself showing me the id i was
showing him the idea the bouncer and i
was like 21 [ __ ] i was like all lit and
just drunk as [ __ ] and then that's the
video last video i have the night and
then my homies told me i just got like
damn you robbed by a stripper and i was
just like [ __ ] man not like rob rock but
she was just like coercing the [ __ ] out
of me just black out and i was like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yo last time i was out of trouble this
girl played me remember rosie let's go
play the shot of me
i'm not that drunk [ __ ]
and then
she was like yo you didn't pay me i go
oh yes i did you're supposed to pay
before and you're trying to get me again
but i wasn't trying to get the bouncers
and all the shows see that's exactly 20
you petty [ __ ]
it was one of those she thought she
thought i was super drunk this joint is
pissing me it's not lighting really
don't know [ __ ] what's going on
just got a nice little relight yeah i
just went out actually so you need to go
to vegas it's [ __ ] uh but after
calling i don't know
uh
no they didn't so there was a time
period there was like a time for like a
month or two where no one had masks and
then they just implemented mask again so
strippers have mass how weird i don't
know i haven't been there since the
stripper they would look like that chick
from mortal kombat yeah remember the
chicken
oh when you rip it off that's kind of
how it looks like bro you see some
chicks when you just like pull the face
mask off on your legs put it back on
come on
yo vegas i've always said like yo let's
go to a show
let's go here let's go experience this
it's never happened i go to strip club
and get too drunk
that's literally what it's like though
because you have plans and
yourself while you're drunk and not
spend too much money yeah it's just like
a chill time yeah that's the last time i
was there
chill out enjoy the view maybe like
get a dance enjoy the viewer like that
yeah you know peaceful enjoy the view
yeah yeah i love it
no it's been a strip club in a long time
to be fair it's been like a couple years
for me
i i there's only one that i could go to
and i was under 21 because they lost
their liquor license
up so that [ __ ] that was a slum strip
club yeah yep if you can't drink they're
doing crazy [ __ ] out there
you know that strip club was infested
with something
[Laughter]
all i heard rumors about the people that
owned the place but i just went there
and had fun
about the place it's like some [ __ ] from
what's that movie with the rock where
you [ __ ] the casino in the strip club
you guys know what i'm talking about
when they cut his stomach open and [ __ ]
that sketchy ass please
dude
it was a fun time every time i went
there but one of my friends went there
and didn't pay for a dance and the
bouncers threw him out
like picked him up and threw him they
like grabbed him and carried those guys
are so i mean
you know the times like i don't care how
big somebody is and then you see
bouncers at strip clubs you go what the
[ __ ]
some of those guys are like six ten yeah
hey man you know you're not that good at
sports just guard these naked chicks
we'll pay you maybe you know one of them
will marry you in five years
that's pretty much a life of a bouncer
i'm assuming right yeah
you ever see a giant man with a really
really pretty chick like oh you used to
be a bouncer and she was a stripper but
oh those kids those aren't your kids huh
no like but
you know that old tale from the sea
um yeah strip clubs man me and rosie
have crazy experiences portland's a wild
place for strip strip clubs really
there's no taxes
and for some reason it's just
portland's wild so this is a crazy place
bro i used to live when i was a kid and
i see all this cool stuff and i couldn't
do any of it so when i went back
portland's [ __ ] cool portland's cool
man i only went there once and it was
during the uh the riots where like a
couple weeks ago it was [ __ ] it was
like just like unfortunate timing and i
was like
i was like
once during the worst part of history
you said i was saying it was like this
is unfortunate like this is [ __ ] it
was it was a pretty crazy thing to see
that like in person i was like wow it's
just like insane like
history type [ __ ] it's crazy yeah how
long were you there
uh i was only there for i was only for
like five days but we were only in
portland for like a day because we were
doing like outdoors you should in oregon
because you know like oregon scenery is
like crazy beautifully waterfalls
i've lived there and all i do is smoke
weed in a forest i've never that's like
what it's like the forestry it's
beautiful but the forest is right by the
street yeah
right
things we haven't found
aliens
there's a lot of [ __ ] in the forest that
i don't trust
would you go to space for you [ __ ] no oh
really
hell no what are they even like planes i
don't know if i would go to space um
really i would when i was like i would
succeed when i like accomplished what i
wanted to accomplish yeah in case why
you die yeah yeah exactly yeah
did we talk about this about my 88 year
old goal do you
know
i want to go smoke opium in china
oh nice
oh but they have
individual rooms and they're all padded
like an insane asylum and somebody hit
like helps you with the opium and then
make sure you don't choke on your tongue
and [ __ ] and throw up
that's fire right that sounds so oh my
god three days of sleep supervised opium
supervised opium trips
yeah you smoke it right out of the
[ __ ] that's the little hat piper too
bad
asian dudes with [ __ ]
beards like accompanying you through
your trip wow like when drugs are an
experience yeah you know right right
like when there's something else
involved
that just sounds fine like i wouldn't
just smoke opium in my bedroom no no no
no no no i would that's too much of a
that's that's so fire that's tight
i don't know
because it's going out yeah what the
[ __ ] yours is just something else yeah
i just rolled it like that
we're just fighting for everything
got to keep chiefing yeah we're just
talking
you know
yo so let's get into it real quick
just for some fan [ __ ] cuz i know if i
was a person that was watching this and
i watched all three of us and like yo i
wish he would answer this ask this
question yeah type [ __ ] right
do you guys
just real quick this is a wee question
we don't really get into this [ __ ]
because it's like some
basic [ __ ] okay but you're dabbing all
day you're dabbing all day too
are you do you like weed more than hash
because i know you like
concentrates more right i like
concentrates more personally but i mean
like if someone's like hey [ __ ] you one
thing for the rest of your life
that's different that's flower for sure
yeah that's 100 actually
because there's way there's i think more
ways to consume flour that's fun you can
vape it you can roll it up
that's exactly true yeah but dabbing is
more fun i guess like in the moment like
i just like the process of like heating
it up like getting the right temperature
like scoop in the dab it's
can you lean the mic down towards you a
little more yeah yeah i feel like it was
going to now yeah that better yeah yeah
way better that's nice
what's the biggest tab you've ever taken
go um at once
nice
yeah i tried to do a gram and it was one
three and i almost came out
i did it but i almost puked you guys
ever thrown above weed
uh the one time i did it was that one
gram dab i didn't throw up but i was
coughing so much i like forced my body
to like yeah that's that's that's normal
yeah i mean i've coughed off i've thrown
up a cough right right outside i don't
think i've ever like thrown up off wheat
that i can remember but yeah i've like
coughed to the point where i almost
threw up i was like yeah you know
that's when it gets real and you're like
[ __ ] i was like you know getting fresh
air yeah
so you guys both recently started
drinking i mean legally oh yeah training
you guys thrown
no
no you don't have any you've ever been
asked to leave
i should just
actually nah i can control myself really
well yeah yeah especially in a public
safety i don't know about a private like
at a party or like a [ __ ]
i try to control myself in those
settings yeah i've only gotten just two
shifts where i couldn't control the way
i was walking once in public
that's the most embarrassing [ __ ]
no you know where you you you walk and
that other step is this way too far you
almost fall and you're kind of leaning
that's exactly what i'm trying to do
you just can't yeah a little spinny just
a little bit
i don't know guys uh it's past 20
minutes
this is what's gonna happen in this
episode ready guys i've been waiting
you kind of got a little thing going
we're gonna do the oprah challenge we're
gonna do the oprah thing if you reach
under your seat there'll be a bag there
right now reach to your left wow
what's going on you're right
my left
don't open this bag yet fully
so i went to dtpg the place you were
talking about the dispensary downtown
right and i told my homie og like yo
we're doing this thing so every 20
minutes
on the dot
we're gonna pull one thing out we all
just eat it drink it or smoke it oh [ __ ]
it's a bag full of weed [ __ ] but like
we're not gonna look no no no no no
we'll all do the same one whatever it is
what's the same thing oh okay but like
you pick i'm like all right that's what
you got we'll pull it out
there's a lot oh [ __ ] there's a lot guys
this is a heavy bag it's funny yeah i'm
feeling it it's like
yes
so you start first pull something out
we'll either smoke it drink it or eat it
[Laughter]
yo this is the job did you know that
this is real
i was hoping that wasn't the first time
oh [ __ ] nah i feel like it's crazy that
you said that
i don't know i just felt something it's
okay it is
citrus oh sativa dominant bug it just
says cannabis infused beverage oh that's
not that bad that's okay let's let's see
yeah it's only 20. it's only 25 yeah
yeah that's cool
nothing crazy and cbd yeah active
performance what is this uh
supposed to be there's a supposed to be
a [ __ ] clue performance drink
interesting bro i gotta be honest i
don't know what it is i like that i just
started putting [ __ ] in a bag yeah
it's dope
that that honestly doesn't smell bad
i don't see like a little remember those
candies fizz you bite them they're hard
crack them and they're like fizzy inside
it tastes kind of like they're it smells
like the redder peeler poke i poked
through
your face tells me
a lot of stuff
oh now it's getting better
not bad your face bro i gotta be honest
if you look at him
from the like neck up he looks like a
[ __ ] christmas card
right now when you went
you look so just reminds me of the
holidays you look so wholesome right
it's a good time and then when you go
right here
there's drugs dude what can i say
eggs that's amazing
i like that all right how do i feel
about the streak yet we're just like
yeah it tastes like if you put
robitussin in water oh i like that
diluted you like it yeah it's almost
like uh i would describe it as like a
really really watered down
right it's like the end of the game
right afterwards frozen you're like oh i
see
do you know what i'm saying like the ass
ends this is kind of brutal honestly
this is really
it's not that bad
this is kind of brutal honestly hmm
it's definitely not did it kind of coat
your teeth oh electrolyte did you shake
it before you opened it yeah oh [ __ ] i
didn't this is what might take it i
guess this is more like a gatorade i'm
going to get towards the ends it tastes
like
[Applause]
[ __ ] [ __ ] off
for everyone driving i'm sorry i don't
know what's going on we're drinking
medicated drinks i just spilled water
all over myself
okay is this water what is this no that
was from the wedding singer some sort of
oh [ __ ] i got water all over myself
sorry
my bad
okay
ready
ready what are we i'm gonna no no you
don't have to chug it oh i feel just
drinking it
you can but okay come down to check i'm
gonna say ready uh question
of course did we talk about
because i remember last time i was
[ __ ] shit-faced
i remember what we talked about i
remember we talked about we're talking
about we like i said i don't i tried to
get like hey
what's your favorite strain uh i'm not
doing that [ __ ] yeah i'm not doing that
but we do talk about drugs and stuff
i know
i know you like drugs do you [ __ ] with
drugs at all
um adidas nah not really i like
psychedelics uh i used to do like a
decent amount of like coke and college
and [ __ ] not decent amount but like
weekends and [ __ ] like parties you know
what i mean i'd get offered it i would
like pitch but i wouldn't really get
bags with myself and [ __ ] so you're a
good student in high school is what i'm
hearing right high school in college i
was young yeah okay you guys are doing
my thing good
that's good yeah good [ __ ] yeah it was
cool it was cool for a while now she's
like nah i gotta move to la and like
[ __ ] school like this is dumb i forget
man because you guys are both the same
age right 22 22. yep nice yeah yeah good
[ __ ] i always forget man we were talking
about the other day like
i'm not oh [ __ ] did i forget i'm i'm not
in my 20s anymore it's [ __ ] weird
because i always forget
like i seriously i started all this [ __ ]
that's dope there's twenty feeling like
that like that's i always feel like the
dream right i always forget like [ __ ]
has it really been that long eat a dick
[ __ ]
all right but hold on sorry back to
drugs before we keep going
psychedelics yes now you like mushrooms
over ass i should have gotten some
mushroom bars too oh
my homie had these the chocolate ones
that look like wonka bars yeah yeah i've
had some of those there's a lot of those
popping up all those little black market
brands are kind of cool
those are crazy the doses on the back
are lies for sure like five people this
is like five pieces of micro dose i did
that in stream because i was like micro
dosing's true and i was tweaking for
sure i was like just looking at the chat
and i was like i was like what's going
on right chat's hard to stare at when
you're [ __ ] up yeah even when you're
taking a lot of damage even when you're
sober it's just like so fast and you're
like it'll move too fast sometimes
exactly
you just can't handle it 100
100
yeah dude but uh speaking of drugs
i know you like drugs and i brought it
up before we started
i saw the coolest brick of my life the
other day because i've seen bricks and
[ __ ] but i saw the nicest the prettiest
little little cocaine key what defines a
pretty brick is it just like nicely it
was so [ __ ] precise you know those
commercials when they're like the new
uh
mitsubishi by something or the new honda
and the guy is
creating the car model with this and
he's like cutting wood shaving wood your
big ass uh yeah you know what i mean
like when they're shaving the wood to
like make the model of the car you know
i'm saying those commercials right it
looked like someone took one of those to
this [ __ ] and like molded it so per you
know when you get a tv and the
styrofoam's like all
has
ridges and edges for the tv to sit
perfect that's exactly what it looked
like wow it was the prettiest thing i
ever saw in my life like i've seen him
before but why i just stopped
i can't yes i can hear you i just
stopped doing blow man did you
yes
it's just scary because like fentanyl
dude no i i didn't want to do any of it
i'm just saying like it was i love
hearing things immaculate see when i
heard you doing drum like i love hearing
that i don't do them but it's so fun
right and now that you stopped good i'm
glad
yeah it's uh it's been about a month
good bro do you feel any better
somewhat yeah i mean it's kind of nice
but at the same time i wasn't really
doing it as much as i used to
but still doing it too much how much
were you doing um
i mean i wouldn't do it every day but
like i don't know maybe like three days
a week i'd do like a like a grammar show
i don't know just a little habit at that
point yeah yeah yeah but i mean i didn't
want to keep doing it so good
i don't know that's dope
thank you
oh you [ __ ] one month sober good
[ __ ] yeah that's dope dude focus scary
man especially here in l.a bro a little
fentanyl will [ __ ] kill you one line
will kill you yeah so that's like wow
like come on
that's not worth it
no no no no no i was just i was just it
made me think of that but no please keep
talking about it no that's that's
so good that you stopped man good good
for you
and if you do it again
be ashamed of but just good for you for
stopping yeah i mean at some point so
now you know you realize last time you
went i can't go
bro [ __ ] it do your thing if you do
drugs every day yeah and you got to make
sure it's nice
it's worth testing [ __ ] you know what i
mean absolutely yeah
i was really stupid and didn't test
anything right that's just like how you
are you think you're invincible and [ __ ]
exactly i swear i used to think that
when i was younger i was like oh i'll
never take anything for
you i'm just like they're all legit now
i was like dude i was so stupid like
that's what i'm saying yeah i would test
if i s if it burned my nose like yo this
[ __ ] but it was mad
it's hella chopped and i look at like oh
it's shiny and some of it's clear [ __ ]
you that's merced though that's meth
city yeah yeah really that's nasty sam
yeah you never smoked meth before right
or snorted it no no neither because you
guys are good people yeah i got a crazy
text from my friend the other day like
high school like childhood friend almost
type of thing and uh he texts me haven't
talked to him in years and he uh sends
me a text and he's like yo i hope you're
doing well i saw you move to la like we
should chill sometime that was the first
little block of text it was like a nice
heartfelt message
and the second block of text was by the
way
i don't know if you tried meth but it's
pretty cheap
that's exactly what it said
he was like it's not as bad as you think
it is i'm just saying if you can get
your hands on some like maybe you should
try it
and i was like
no i don't think you say like yo i
started doing it he just has hit you up
like yes you can [ __ ] get it yeah i
appreciate it
yeah
like
no like i said i haven't talked to him
in like two or three years hitting me
actually maybe a bit of nowhere nice
thanks bro thanks i was like i hope
you're doing well too maybe he was like
you though because this won't tinder ask
girls do you smoke meth yeah you should
be on tinder but you smoke math yeah
dude did you find any
uh there's a couple that said yes
there's one girl that actually like went
with it and then
you say math or is it like is it speed
what's it called no i say man oh it's
not bad i don't beat around the bush
speed to me could be like oh you sh
in the 70s yeah because some people see
still say speed and think coke yeah i'm
like oh you brought different kind of
speed to the park because the way i see
it like yo if i walked in and went yo
here's some meth you guys look at me
like oh bro yeah what if i do the same
thing with some coke
different tone you know yeah
it means a lot of things that means a
lot of things man
what was i about to say you're homie the
meth thing i [ __ ] i know he's he
might be off
what a cool guy yeah i hope he's doing
well
if you don't know if you heard about
this meth thing
you should surprise yeah
[Music]
this is not an ad read okay but yo if
you ever had meth you should you should
try it it's good that's exactly what he
did he slipped in an address
that's what he did bro that's what he
did i love it yo one time speaking of
friends and math
um
one time when i was still delivering
pizza i was like 21
and this guy yeah [ __ ] this guy sean
i haven't seen him since high school and
he's from one of the story times where
we were running from the cops and he got
caught and i didn't and then i ended up
getting caught anyway it's that guy
brandon's house i mean that guy's sean's
house oh bro
this [ __ ] i delivered a pizza to
him like yo you look kind of tweaked oh
[ __ ] i haven't seen you in a minute all
these are processing as i'm like yo
but i'm like oh [ __ ] oh damn no
you know like you can see it on your
face you've been picking [ __ ]
like you can see when someone's on meth
and i haven't seen him in a minute but
teeth too teeth
his teeth are cool
yeah that's either cool
and
he's like oh yeah man thanks for the
pizza blah blah i'm like all right cool
i haven't seen you in a minute good [ __ ]
you get my number like [ __ ] careful like
guess my [ __ ] my homie maybe i was
dripping i'm not tripping
he texted me like two days later are you
ready for this
he texts me hey what's up man you think
you can get me a job right over there
i'm going to school and shout i'm like
oh all right cool yeah just put your
application in i'll tell my boss that
you're my homie and if you want to work
i'll get you a job don't trip yeah if
if you put an application in and like
he's cool with you have an interview i
can't just give him a job
five
minutes later
after i text him back
if you don't give me this job i'm gonna
kill you
like that as i was delivering another
pizza
and i'm like what
what'd you say to
i went
and i never talked to the guy again
i believe you yeah like i believe you i
understand also you're twacked and i'm
gonna kill you if you try to do anything
weird to me like
like [ __ ] you
but no joke dude like yo man i'd be so
sick you got me a job like sick yeah of
all this stuff information information
to help if you don't give me this job
i'm going to kill you
people switch up on you man not even
that he came in and put an application
about a week later guys
i think he forgot because meth heads
will be like oh it's
what year he's probably up for like five
days straight he's probably for days
days days days yeah yeah he's probably
off he doesn't remember none of that
like my dad and my uncle they'd be like
i was for [ __ ] seven days i was up
for 12.
after about because i've been up like
four days straight but not off drugs of
[ __ ] soda and cow and chicken and
cartoon network marathons as a kid
but you hallucinate about day three you
do you hallucinate hard you've never
been awake
you start the [ __ ] you're thinking
you think you see it
do you know what i'm saying yeah like a
shadow but i done it off blow before i
was oh true true and a little bender i
was like laying in my bed and i thought
i was like i thought i heard my name
getting called and [ __ ] i was just
a tweet it's [ __ ] weird
i hate it that's true good
don't you don't want that feeling bro
that's the worst thing you know i've
stayed up that long
playing games when i was a kid dude
as a kid it was bad um
two years ago i stayed it for like oh
like three days three and a half
just smoking bowls and playing madden
cause rosie was gone and i'm like
i was editing and i was like you know
what smoke and i can't sleep at all
but if i get tired i'll try and i just
broke past that little wave and i was
like all right sun's coming up i'm not
going to sleep that's day one then day
two i'm like [ __ ] at my homies all
night [ __ ] i'm just gonna push and then
at like day three i remember i was
smoking a bowl and i thought i saw
someone walk by me
like oh i'm done bro i'm [ __ ] dumb
going to sleep
but no no drugs it's just my brain sucks
it doesn't turn off sometimes and i just
can't sleep
i don't know if you ever felt that i i
mean i sleep pretty well honestly yeah
i've been i've been fortunate in that
department i sleep scoot in this a
little bit yeah there you go there we go
yeah
yeah i couldn't hear you beautiful
i'm sorry
yeah bro i have a left i gotta re i
gotta reignite this i know same marty
can you hear us
i don't got any headphones on so oh [ __ ]
here you're laughing she can hear us
right okay sorry
i know you guys
are all back there and i can see you
through the smoke
[ __ ] like that but um
damn it
back to this brick of drugs so anyway
i'm looking at this [ __ ] break and
i'm holding it and i know all right
there's a trick my friend plays
i know there are new people in the room
because i don't know everybody who knows
but i know there's i think i've just
said this before
i know there's new people in the room
when i walk in i'm like oh there's a
giant gun in here he never has him out
but his thing is like
always just leave it out with new people
because then they go
[ __ ] this because then you're like oh
damn who's in those other rooms maybe i
shouldn't try to rob this place because
people are weird especially doing
[ __ ] massive amounts of drugs
but um when i walk down like oh p90
these guys are new and then i'm like
because you know you forget you don't
want to be like hey what's up man nice
to meet you like we met 12 times bro
that's my word i hate doing that to
people like i forget that i met somebody
yeah yeah so i always do like hey what's
up and they're like nice to meet you oh
you guys are new there's guns everywhere
[ __ ] yeah but that's when i saw the
brick and i can see him as he's showing
they get one of some lines and he brings
out a brick i'm like oh you're trying to
scare these guys i can see what you know
they mean like oh you're trying to scare
these new these new buyers because he
got a gun he brought out a brick when
there's a plate of coke that he always
keeps in a drawer it's right i know i
know where i can walk through his house
blindfold and take out his drugs for him
i know where they're at he just brought
a break to be like yeah
by the way
don't try to rob me
oh my god it's have you ever seen the
washed drug damn this is a drug this is
drugs you ever seen the coke that gets
washed
i don't think i've like seen the
flavored drugs you ever tried the
flavored cokes oh no bro you've never
seen this
oh so what do you mean flavored so ready
you know how they uh
you know they wash hash
yeah through the through the screens
right oh my homie because when he showed
me it he had like five bags and all of
them just looked slightly different i'm
like what the [ __ ] he's like yeah this
is this layer this layer this slime like
what did you say he's like i got some
strawberry drugs he's like strawberry
coke i'm like what'd you just [ __ ]
say i mean
i heard about it in vegas like or in
colorado like six years ago ago that's
fake drugs or
and
no so basically you wash it with and
when it when it gets wet like caked like
hash right you let it dry out like when
it's wet but you put fruit in the same
little box that you're drying it in it's
so insane but it takes on it takes on
the flavor of what you have he's like
that's pineapple that's this that's this
and i don't do drugs anymore but i went
like this ah let me try it
and it tastes like strawberry and then
my face wouldn't [ __ ] melt
that's so dangerous actually no to wash
it just for now
i meant like the term is in like how
[ __ ] really good yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like being like
in the
no
i just meant like dude if it tastes like
strawberry get me a little drunk and
i'll i can see rosie it's like moving in
the background right now and i know
she's explaining it back there
so it's like concentrated cocaine isn't
it like crack
no like um
say you have 10 grams
the impurities impurities no matter what
you know like you've still got
impurities right right yeah and he's
like if i have 10 grams i'm gonna end up
with like six five six three because the
impurities are up here he's like yeah
you can still snort that's cool but down
here is my he's all heady there's drugs
and it's really [ __ ] funny that's him
it's really amazing
he's picky
big time he'll i see this will take mad
dabs and then snort something i'm full
what the [ __ ] he's like you don't like
roller coasters
and that was the best line i ever heard
in my life i was like i ain't gonna ask
nothing left i'm done you're like roller
coaster oh you're a [ __ ] baller
um you know that guy's scary actually
it's so he's the guy he's a monster guy
he's the coolest what an animal he's the
one that told me to get into crypto like
[ __ ] 2015. damn cause you guys [ __ ]
with it right yeah i could cook them i
don't still you tried to explain it to
me last time and i got some of it yeah
yeah we get some of it and then now i'm
looking at all my homies like i lost a
lot of money on this one but i gained
money in this bike so you broke even
right so what what the [ __ ] was the
point i still don't get it cause i don't
know what to invest in but i know you're
on that [ __ ] heavy and you were saying
you're on it yeah i'm on it somewhat
yeah i just don't know what to do bro
because i know people talk about this
gonna hold it like i don't think there's
any like it's just really really early
right now like it's like really really
early like it's like being really early
to like an industry that's like not even
popping yet it's like having like a
computer and internet and an email in
like 98.99 you know like before the
dot-com boom where like everything
popped off but like
it's it's exactly like that so we're
just real early it really is that's like
the best way to put it like it's
something that has such a guaranteed
future
and it's only going to grow like right
now i'm just going to stop using it yeah
just like online money like most of our
money's online anyway it's just numbers
on the screen you're like bank accounts
and all that [ __ ]
cash in a bit a minute right right
that's
yeah exactly
and then we know like banks aren't
secure like they're always leaking
passwords and [ __ ] like you always hear
about it and [ __ ] you know what i mean
like you see those like data breaches
that come out it's like wells fargo and
then yeah yeah
yeah all those like pop off and it's
like well my shit's exposed to like this
[ __ ] crazy amount of people but like
crypto helps that blockchain helps that
you know i don't even know what
blockchain means
blockchain's like a crazy info it's like
a little info something like the easiest
way to explain the blockchain is like
you know a puzzle if you have like a
puzzle piece on the board there's only a
specific place a piece can go
like because of the surrounding pieces
you know what i mean that's exactly what
blockchain is but with pieces of
information so it's verified by like the
information around it so nothing can be
like faked so you can't post like
something you're explaining it that was
like perfect because i get it now
i understand what that meant it's just
like a connected way to like verify that
like information is real and like legit
and like
just like
verified by the ownership you know who
owns it and that's got you got it yeah
yeah like a real way to track
information that you can't hide it's
like the main thing
but you can huh
real quick it's been 20 more minutes
let's get a little something it's been
20 more minutes so let's reach into this
open bag all right so whose turn is it
to pick now you last
me you pick okay okay i got you i catch
you let's do a little did you look or
did you just do a little random i mean i
looked but didn't really get an idea of
what anything was because like i i
quickly put it back yeah but i'll do a
little i'll just do a little recharge
yeah that's good
oh there's another drink i don't know
about that there's a lot of [ __ ] in
there
some of those drinks might be something
scary you never know
i like the feel of this box oh
i
i got the same milligrams but that's i
can't eat that so oh my chocolate it's
the chocolate [ __ ] yeah gotcha gotcha so
uh
let's start it up
if you're watching the car please be
safe but also we are eating massive
amounts of stuff this is all edible
package opening
oh this has this needs scissors
no maybe not yeah no this this does
let me see what it looks like
some cool little chocolates going on oh
that's cool that's a lot of packaging
how'd you get i think this is exhibits
brand right or something like yeah
they got in some controversy recently
they did why yeah because like the
napalm name is like kind of oh yeah like
what the [ __ ] i was like dude i'm
vietnamese like my people got kind of
[ __ ] up and i was like yeah it's just
like whatever
yeah like that's literally the people
that were like trying to like complain
but no like vietnamese people were
complaining it was like other people
that were saying it was defensive you're
offended no i'm telling you you're
offended i'm like no no that's not like
that and you're like no it's [ __ ] up
and you're like
all right i guess like it's [ __ ] up i
don't know i'm not trying to get
canceled you know it is [ __ ] up oh i
don't have scissors
is that a box i'll use the box cutter
that's fine
i'll use the box cutter
no i just like nick can you grab that
from here
thank you
you're amazing
so i guess we don't have scissors in
this place
i'm using a [ __ ] box cutter
i've seen final destination
all right here we go
final destination a thousand ways to die
all those a little scary you're like
[ __ ] so you found this nation it was so
scary
like she couldn't really do realistic
[ __ ] like she can really just pop off
when the [ __ ] log went through that
fool's face in part two i was done wow
the highway yeah there's no [ __ ]
full bottles of anything in that front
seat [ __ ] that [ __ ] get it open
i did i just ripped it oh yeah that's
fine nice that's what you got to do yeah
yo this one piece has the same amount
that's crazy oh i like things like that
though because i don't like like eating
a lot of drinking a lot
little do you guys know this mushrooms i
just switched it out
i'm not going to tell you guys the full
bar in eighth i'm trying to not sleep
until my flight so i mean you're not
gonna sleep to your flight i don't plan
to what time is your flight uh it's like
8 30 in the morning yes
yeah that's what i usually do if you do
the mushrooms uh the mushroom bar you'll
probably be all right
nice you like chocolate or gummy edibles
better
i like what kind of gummies yeah
smokies
space jams are the [ __ ]
i think that's all the gummies i really
can try
i don't know there's some like vegan
gummies coming out i feel like they're
like
more right right i see a lot more
popping off
all right so why you guys eating that
let's take a shot
absolutely okay
absolutely
let's do this
everyone driving i'm sorry doing drugs
and drinking can't do none of that [ __ ]
and if you are bro [ __ ] chill yeah
come on
it's [ __ ] up
all right here we go
yo so what happened to the to the car to
the lip what happened
oh just some l.a driveways man i tried
to hit them all sideways this one just
got me just like scrape and it was i
scraped sometimes and it's all right
because it's like it's whatever and then
this one was just like a scrape
and i was like oh bro
it just plopped the [ __ ] off and i knew
it came off and i was like man that's
unfortunate ugh i tried to get a white
tape it like clear tape and underneath
it just didn't work
so i got a new one coming and that one's
gonna get like uninstalled reinstalled
whatever [ __ ]
he goes sir thank you at least brutal
bro the roads are [ __ ] horrible
that's like the one thing man yeah yeah
it's all bad out here i uh this area is
a little bit traffic's are awful here
yeah
traffic's bad but you're also from a
place with no traffic yeah but i mean
even then like i've i've traveled a fair
bit like around the country and like
it's so bad you know what it is though
you're in ubers when you're driving you
get to smoke weed and do it there's no
traffic yeah i mean you don't mind it
yeah at all so it's pretty much
irrelevant it's understandable you went
to new york recently right they're kind
of recently or not no i've been in new
york me neither i mean i went when i
went when i was like really young but i
don't really count that okay yeah i feel
that have you been here
really we're just talking about this huh
yeah yeah i've never been to you i'm
supposed to go and then the [ __ ]
world's closed
yeah that was pretty much yeah i was
supposed to go and like i wanted to i
wanted to go to vegas but you could
still go i i am going but i'm saying
like i wanted to go like i mean i plan
to go by the end of the year i don't
really have anything booked yet go ahead
any time
i mean if you're down i'll definitely
come there too maybe yeah let's [ __ ]
party let's party hard to speak let's go
crazy in vegas i'm just let's go i just
don't know what to do
what do you mean what's the [ __ ] way
hey stripper stay about that far away
from here i don't know how clean you are
also why am i here
[Music]
why the [ __ ] did i step in this place
i literally don't know what else to do
dude we can just go gamble and get drunk
[ __ ] hate gambling oh you don't like
it i'd rather go give my money like this
go rosy here's throw strippers of that
naked girl no
then go hey 40 year old man take my
[ __ ] money out there so there's no
there's that thrill though there's the
thrill
of gambling it's really
no way
no i don't get it i don't like it not a
single form of gambling not cards not
anything
i mean i just don't have fun doing it
really
because it's like
you're gonna take my money [ __ ] you i'm
gonna buy weed
that's how it feels
yeah i always have that feeling i guess
i feel like the you think about it is
like you're paying for the experience
you know right right
you know you're going expecting to lose
a certain amount for sure for sure you
lose it that's crazy to me
it's fun it's fine it's fine but then
again i get that i get if that's what
you like because when you get the drinks
in the environment and the high
efficiency i guess that's cool that's
cool
i think i'd be a lot more right yeah i
do online gambling pretty much oh yeah
the casino ones are dope bro we'll go to
some vegas ones in there yeah like being
at the table is so dope like it's a
different experience
at the table it's dope
all right i think i told you my 18th
birthday i went gambling
i was up like 500 bucks all right can
you gamble at 18. i know there's a
couple of thousands
said it's chancy um
18th birthday i was up hell of money and
then they switched dealers and i didn't
know that's like yo you leave right then
that happens
i didn't know lost all my money and i
lost like 300 more bucks
and as i was walking out i remember like
y'all i'm never gambling again that was
my time
i'm [ __ ] over it you've been gambling
since that's so terrible
you're a dollar a slot machine while
everyone's chilling gambling all right
cool back to the room i'm [ __ ] done
yeah
you've tried it like here and then
you're just like it's not for me or like
i just
i'd rather buy something
that's really what it is
do you do something else in my town
there's like gas stations that have like
little slot parlors you're from that
kind of place oh the places that like
the aliens invaded i really i really
debated like getting drunk and going in
and just doing it
there's a reason that 80 year old man
sits there all day honestly bro yeah
he's he's on to something he must have
won time once a month and never left if
i could just tap out after that moment i
could really be honest online like wait
you were with me no so my my homies
little brother is addicted you would
tell me about it okay so i was telling
you yeah the [ __ ] you just spin oh i
don't get that i can't do that one
that feels rigged to me that just feels
like i'm not winning
but like that
yeah for sure the other one's like kind
of rigged you know like every house has
an advantage always but like it's more
like winnable i just feel like i i
prefer to play cards when i gamble like
either blackjack or like yeah yeah but
that i still feel like a computer like
uh i mean i like the real dealers and
[ __ ] it's cool yeah yeah i'm sorry sorry
here of course we talked about las vegas
and they just stopped marty do you want
a shot of this
all right here we go
geez
that's something i don't know maybe i'll
start liking a
gambling again soon
i think you should man
so
you guys both gaming out right you're
you game heavy right you do two uh yeah
at the center i used to a lot heavier
but now i just do it like on twitch and
everything but it's fun yeah yeah
you know how to do overlays and all that
[ __ ] you guys do overlays on twitch and
[ __ ] yeah yeah uh i mean
right you can switch cameras yeah yeah
yeah i only have one camera for my
stream okay do that much like i just
chill out i need to learn how to do this
[ __ ] it's really easy you can do it like
you just watched like two three youtube
videos and you'll never have yeah
there's some long lines
i can't do it i can't learn like that i
have to say y'all do it for do it all
right let me do it again and i'll try it
i can't do the online tour like you you
always this learns lives off youtube
tutorials doing crazy [ __ ] you can learn
like anything else remember i think
there was times he was like i don't even
know how to do this like three hours
later so i watch this damn tutorial it's
[ __ ]
every time
yeah he's like you always learned
something though did you see that guy uh
in the olympics i want to say this from
like a country in africa and he threw
travelings and uh he just learned from
youtube
like he didn't have like the means to
you know that's crazy and he just
watched youtube videos and he got like
to the olympics and he's pretty fresh
holy [ __ ] yeah he went into metal or
anything uh i'm not sure if he plays but
it was like dope just being yeah yeah
qualifying the qualifying games and
everything yeah that's pretty cool yo
did you watch the olympics yeah a lot of
it yeah i tried to watch as much as i
could i only watched it when i was drunk
at the bar
that's fine
dude i was bored on like a sunday at 3
p.m i hit a chili's nice chili's chili's
crazy bro you definitely need to move
because i know what that is that's my
that's my tone everything
is applebee's i was just [ __ ] stoned
and i was like yeah
like two or three chilis
you just i was born i went to a chili's
yo that at that point you got to get out
of that town i i listen i know you're
not old
i know
you're not that [ __ ] was kind of lit
though
oh for sure you get that [ __ ] hot ass
dip
oh
chili's is not bad so wait you just
wanted chili to drink or something yeah
i was just bored so i went in there to
drink nice [ __ ] yeah dude you gotta
do yeah
i gotta do something exactly i had
nothing better to do i was over in the
area i was i was trying to you know
maybe shop a little bit nice
i want to get stronger pre-game it you
know big deal
shopping drunk is dangerous
before i get drunk is really risky yeah
i can shop high because i'm like too
analytical and i just won't buy anything
and i'm shopping drunk i'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i've done some
terrible decision shopping drawings i've
never done that we talked i talked about
this to my homie a couple weeks ago
hey i was all [ __ ] faced i bought this
but you bought something [ __ ] up
when i got my first card
card all right [ __ ] 20 i got [ __ ]
faced and i bought so much [ __ ]
like a lot i bought a lot of like
seinfeld posters and [ __ ] that's a good
box that's awesome yeah oh it was cool
it's just fire purchase for sure when i
got them in the mail my for real food i
bought all you know what i mean like
because the thing is i'm dumb and i was
buying them individually checking out
yeah and then i was paying for
just shipping
[Music]
i don't know one of those sites bro
karma loop back then or something oh
[ __ ] i remember those days
dr jays
yes wow that's like crazy internet
doctor james was a uh online
you know
it's like the mall online right
you pick a brand
go pick a outfit or pick up this a
collection like oh [ __ ] i was out there
selling weed trying to buy [ __ ]
clothes
like a [ __ ] stereotypical dumb [ __ ]
literally like some you ain't never make
it out here man you're not making it out
of your head out of your city
yo how was that it's pretty good i like
it yeah you don't really taste the weed
at all just some chocolate oh you don't
it's pretty good do you want to try one
of these edibles
sure it needs to yeah
um there's a stack you know where
they're at by the officers
towels can you bring those also rosie
sorry guys we're all [ __ ]
in the middle of the show my bad my bad
um
so back to
the olympics i think i've probably
watched like 10 hours
really hell yeah it's awesome yo if you
haven't watched the olympics you're
missing out on the coolest [ __ ] the
world does
collectively whatever olympics clips
coming to my youtube recommended
you should start watching all the world
records there was really 30 world
records broke this year i'm exaggerating
but
holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] women's weightlifting every girl
that went up new world record new world
record new idea it was [ __ ] amazing
some of the girls that were like 120
pounds were
clean and jerk like almost 360 340. damn
holy [ __ ] gotta see some of this [ __ ]
the women's heavyweights some of those
girls are like 300 pounds like pretty
big ladies yeah and they were power
cleaning and lifting like the girl i
think
was 486. wow
bro those dudes wow like 150 pounds
literally power cleaning 500 pounds it
doesn't make [ __ ]
sense right there super humans dude
superhumans it's pretty cool to see them
it's cool to see
these people just doing [ __ ] that you're
like you gotta watch the [ __ ]
olympics man it's it's [ __ ]
ridiculous my grandma gotta get [ __ ]
kid though that's why no i'm good i'm
good uh you gotta watch it man holy [ __ ]
only happens once every four years we
could be at war with the country and go
like this take a look man
right through the same country why can't
they just do it all the time
you could do it during the during the
competition
yeah yo it's crazy i watch the swimming
synchronized swimming yeah watch that on
drugs
it looks like a simulation thank you
it doesn't even look real
like really you can't imagine watching
that [ __ ] while you're tripping
their legs in is like this
and i'm sitting there watching like what
the [ __ ] is happening how do you learn
how to like synchronize so well i don't
understand that [ __ ]
something like that the only thing i can
think is like dude there's no way
i'm
every time i see the triple jump i go
nope done oh i did i was at a triple
jump in high school did you yeah yeah i
feel like the triple jump i like the
triple jump oh [ __ ]
athletic as [ __ ] yeah yeah i was the
only oh i don't know i'm skinny too but
um
yeah that [ __ ] makes sense it's still a
long jump too
that's fun yeah yeah triple jump is day
it's like yo don't [ __ ] break your
leg jump on it again and then jump yeah
it's like the hop skip were you good at
it yeah it was pretty nice really i mean
like i placed it a couple meets but
that's that's what i've gotta come up
with
i got a couple things yeah for sure but
i didn't go to like you know like the
regionals or anything like that but i
mean like i went to damn trip
when i was a kid yeah i thought it was
so cool doing the spin it really i
thought
man
under the chin like oh bro i thought it
was so [ __ ] cool i would always get
the uh the good looks and like the
respect though because i was like always
the lightest skin kid you know what i
mean like
every single jump event type [ __ ]
just be like hey like what the [ __ ] are
you doing here like let's go and i'll be
like yeah yep i mean like i'm just
jumping man you know
probably not
i mean watching the 400 meters watching
all that [ __ ] watching this little white
dude from i think it was
germany
you know the 400 meter and you jump over
those you jump over those things while
you're sprinting
his full world record 400 meters
and he matched the 400 meters that
people were doing without hurdles
he hit the hurdles at the same speed
that people were hitting without her
this little white dude was tiny
i don't [ __ ] understand
they're like machines they're machines
they're little they're perfect
especially on that stage you only get
one chance yeah this year dude you gotta
just just watch
type it in youtube i need to watch this
gold medal wins 2020 olympics all right
i'll see only the cool [ __ ] watching
boxing this kid from uh i'm from merced
but hilary's not far the full [ __ ]
place second in boxing split this fool's
face open uh it was good [ __ ] damn i've
really skateboarding was in it for the
first time
i was in this year really and bmxing
it's sick bro watching the 13 year old
got gold and women skating this little
girl from japan and the i think the
silver and bronzers were also like 14.
japan really and they're 13 13 14.
the the men's winner was [ __ ] from
japan i think it's actually the sickest
skaters in the world
they don't they don't break
the girl from brazil is 13 too let's do
drugs bro we're over time about the
olympics a lot but still it's good [ __ ]
i [ __ ] with the olympics since i was a
kid i've been watching this [ __ ] oh yeah
it's been 20 more minutes all right damn
it
i like that it's gonna say that i think
it's your turn to pick something now oh
oh yeah i'll pick
all right still probably always win too
shout out to america baby you're coming
out russia's
[Music]
now he's doing [ __ ] better help ads
michael phelps which is ty shout out to
better help yeah
they're the opening sponsor to this
episode tonight oh [ __ ] i know you guys
don't know [ __ ]
same brand deals as michael phelps
that's good okay
it says liquid joint oh that's
interesting i hope it's not like a
syringe because i'm not going to smoke
that on here
um
it's white
or you know
maybe oh yours is green is mine a little
different yep okay
this right here for everyone driving
we're picking out other [ __ ] to smoke
it's heavy it is right oh it's a
it's a liquid it's a shot oh let's take
a real shot and this oh
it is
yo this smells
like orange sun gets soda and i'm so
excited really let me uh mine is lime if
you're really down you'll snort it
cause you're still drinking
jesus
down here damn near strawberry is mine
our table on mine is a little high up i
got a strawberry is a great fruit you
got a top three fruit
top three
[ __ ] grapes
strawberries purple red green yeah yeah
yeah yeah don't matter really greener
you have no preference no as long as
they're not the baby table bitch-ass
table grapes with yeah
like my grandma grace has
[Music]
bro oh my [ __ ] oranges no interesting
i just eat all fruit at once because i
know it's good for you so i'll just try
to eat it all as much because i [ __ ]
despise mango and i wish i liked it whoa
my mangoes are probably my favorite
that's [ __ ] up i wish i liked it
mangoes
are really good rosie loves you
[ __ ] hate it yeah that's the craziest
thing it's in something i'm like oh
whoa what's good
i guess
i drink it
i don't like cantaloupe
yo this is what happens sometimes when
everybody's just kind of we're talking
about our favorite apples and fruits i
[ __ ] love it
i love it what's your favorite what was
your favorite oh fuji apples are done
they're like thick as [ __ ] and yeah
so big bro that's reasonable
they're so big
to say the least cheers i hope this
isn't sucked
it sucked wow that's awful wow that's so
bad
it's actually horrible for being 10
milligrams you'd expect it to be like 50
or something it's [ __ ] horrible yeah
it's really bad it tastes like a candle
it's a real
flavor in mine kind of
made it a little
a little okay going down but the
actually doesn't go anywhere yeah an
actual shaman made me throw up after
that i was [ __ ]
all right
i don't know how i feel about that yeah
i don't feel good about it for sure
yo
real quick
yes
wait
oh okay cool i was like this is expired
ah but i read it it's not it's 12. it's
12.9 i thought it was at 2 9.
oh that would have been so good
[Music]
um
so out of everybody at this table
this guy's monetized on youtube crazy
yeah yeah yeah you just got monetized i
remodeled it nice same same really
you're my god i got the join button and
[ __ ] nice yeah but none of my videos get
monetized but i mean
you're
like
yeah yeah yeah it wasn't like that for
like two years and i saw like a whole
bunch of people getting in i was like
that [ __ ] it's still really good i had
it for like a month you got like hella
members and i was like how excited to
produce content yeah stop for like two
years i applied every single month just
denied tonight tonight every single
month for two years and then all of a
sudden they just accepted me that's fire
let me take that back so me as the only
person i monetize at this table
holy [ __ ] i didn't know you [ __ ] got
monetized too that's crazy yeah it's
pretty sick they let they monetize a
weed channel that shocks me right right
but i mean none of my videos
i guess yeah yeah like even if i tried
to like do their little request to
review and like i think one of my videos
i bleeped out the sensors and like
blurred the wheat and everything and
they just didn't they're like nah sorry
we're not gonna monetize this but it's
cool to have like that unlocked yeah i
mean where's the want
button
that's how i feel my heart
but your videos your videos are getting
age restricted right
before they come out sometimes really
bro it's crazy how do you do you ever
get them like unage restricted or
anything thank you
um i'm too afraid to ask because i don't
want them to delay yeah that's how i
feel that's how i feel just do it but
yeah but my shit's mad explicit
sometimes i'm showing too many pegs but
a lot of your things aren't aren't age
restricted it's crazy of my videos
lately
like if they yeah oh yeah 100 guys old
ones a lot lately right 100 i've been
able to get every video for a minute
it sucks like they at least they don't
delete me anymore you know they usually
delete my videos so i'll take it okay
age restriction right like restrictions
i get [ __ ] every time damn it's crazy
barely wow i get age restricted before
my video comes out like before the
premiere
yeah while i'm uploading so i'm like
okay during premiere people can report
it that kind of makes sense like
whatever haters
but during maybe one in ten videos oh my
god one and twenty is not interesting
that's amazing it's crazy it's amazing
that doesn't mainly do just like
gameplay story yeah yeah yeah that's
true that's chosen so it can't say the
topic
yeah the topic isn't what does it it's
the footage because i just story times
they're getting [ __ ] agents like
crazy and i don't eat yeah i just smoked
a [ __ ] joint talking about
whatever yeah
yeah yeah
it's just interesting
okay i got it it's crazy i get it
it's crazy
now i'm getting played with the age
restrictions for sure like i get [ __ ]
but the fact that they should so brutal
to you it's horrible dude it's insane
it's insane the numbers you get i can't
believe it
have you guys ever deleted off instagram
yeah for sure i could delete it i got
deleted three times in one week
did you get the page back yeah oh okay
but then i just got like okay that's
fine that's fine
i haven't gotten permanently deleted
thankfully which is crazy but you've
been in a lot longer than me i guess but
i mean at the same time it's like you
would expect that i would get it you
know what i mean okay you've warned me
quite a few times for sure yeah so i
mean i i i don't know
have you guys ever internally flipped a
table over and just
oh i just did right now like yeah yeah
you take company tech companies
i get deleted a lot when i do that i'm
trying to like say that and like even
like show cash for like giveaways they
can't do that or like you have to be so
subtle
no i got delete my post got deleted it
was just a
cookie no packaging
what like
yeah some random things get deleted for
me like i had um some stop asian hate
two posts and they both got yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying i guess you
could tell where they stand
yeah it was crazy bro it was crazy i was
like
[ __ ] him uh no i didn't even try to i
was like yeah don't even get it right
just go not even worth it i'm gonna
listen this up to just racism
this is racist
[ __ ] man ig racism that's so funny i had
an account it was just me going hey it's
my new account guys thank you so much
for following and it got deleted
and rosie's post with me in them get
deleted or the stories get deleted dude
i posted a screenshot of the banned
message from my main account on my
backup account and that got like
deleted it's [ __ ] and a warning on
that backup account damn
what's even wrong with that
um
it's their notification i put go eating
shrooms and go into the dodger game and
that got deleted and reported for
self-harm
yeah it's always something random i feel
like it's just people it's like an
automated instagram
same thing as youtube you know like a
lot of the stuff that they demonetize
they they you know age restrict they
don't actually watch right right because
it's like right away it's like yeah it's
like some sort of like system they have
crazy algorithms it's insane
it's so crazy the [ __ ] that that robots
yeah 100 they scan your video and just
detect like all the audio i say [ __ ] a
lot
yeah that'll do it yeah that'll do it
100
i wish i didn't cut so much
yeah but it's just natural you guys see
my mom you met my mom
that [ __ ] is just like breathing [ __ ]
it's a habit just a word it's just a
word yeah yeah it's just like an
irreplaceable word like what am i
supposed to say instead of like [ __ ]
like just like something darn it yo
right
such a bad i don't remember her name i
had a teacher all the time because i
always said that sucks
and the [ __ ] really hated me for saying
the word that sucks it was the seventh
oh oh it's kind of old for all that she
helped she'd legitimately try to tell me
and make me say oh that's the pits
and
yeah oh that's the pits so no you're
gonna say that's that's the pits from
now on like oh
in the 40s they should do this and say
that [ __ ] and then
[Music]
wow you know what i'm saying well
everyone was black and white yeah i told
her i even said and that's probably why
she i was a smart ass kid i was a
[ __ ] but it's not the 50s anymore
and maybe that made her upset but i
still passed her [ __ ] class
good it's good it's good um so you're a
good kid in school i mean you did good
in school yeah you went to college right
all right yeah my mom just like pushed
me like super heavy to do school and
[ __ ] and i was like
not gonna be like i don't know the only
options were like you're super good at
like sports or school and i was like i
was just decent sports and i was like
i'm not good enough to like you know
what i mean like pursue any sport so i
was like i'll just like do school [ __ ] i
guess you know what i mean study a
little bit i didn't really know what
else i wanted to do you know what i mean
i wanted to do like family was pushing
me to like
oh it was a stereotypical [ __ ] right 100
did it make you make you like you should
be good at math type [ __ ] yeah yeah well
i was good at math so [ __ ]
i can't do math for [ __ ] really yeah
yeah i don't know what it is like it's
literally like an asian gene or
something because i just do math like i
don't know it's [ __ ] crazy i can't do
math versus this [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude i mean
i told you in the car i don't know how
to do long division because i missed
that first day in fourth grade right and
when i came back they were like so step
five and say i go oh what the [ __ ]
happened yeah so i faked it i told you i
faked it i still don't know how to do it
and i got math dude in the year eighth
grade nice
student of the year pulled it off yeah
yeah i lied the whole time in my head
just like yo you know that's why i can
do math quick in my head nice but that's
definitely i'm so trash like quadratic
formulas oh [ __ ] all that like yeah i
only need to use that did you ever go to
school college no i dropped out of high
school oh wait we talked about this
that's right that's right yeah we're not
going to do that [ __ ] go to school
it's not nice
yeah yeah yeah everyone out there go to
school but at least high school you know
college is becoming a lot more optional
nowadays 100 but high school is like i
feel like you got to go to high school
you know you got your ged
did you i worked at popeyes
we were the fast food yeah the funniest
thing about my job was that it was in
high school and it was a brand new
popeyes and all my friends were looking
for jobs so we were like if we all just
applied the whole crew and then like
pretty much every single person got
accepted so we were just running the
popeyes they'd be like homie in the
drive-through i would be in the middle
like homie in the other place and it'd
just be like all us and like some
bitch-ass manager and we'd just be like
try to get high
no no no not really just like right
before i started smoking so i was just
like sober just like chilling there oh
you just gotta check right right right
and you kept it yeah it's like right
before i started smoking
yeah yeah
popeyes and wendy's how was that
wendy's was i mean wendy's was actually
pretty decent is that [ __ ] for real not
frozen yeah actually wow wendy's just
not heard it from the source no joke
actually [ __ ] source
the change thing about wendy's is they
made me clean every night that's why i
quit i hated i hated closing closing is
the worst you just stay so late closing
is so shitty dude no matter what closing
is the absolutely worst because you have
fun in the bathroom you have to mop the
floors you have to mop the kitchen
it's the it's the shittiest thing ever
for sure like it's terrible you do at
wendy's like where was your job you
froze you kind of depended every day
like the miscellaneous
drive-through sometimes they tell you to
go to the cashier yeah they would they
would train you low-key these fast food
places i was i was skilled at that
i was doing things
you have to work real quickly right
right i remember it was like an upgrade
to do the drive through though like you
had to be there for like a few months
type [ __ ] no wendy's makes good food
except for the chili the chili is [ __ ]
up really what do you mean [ __ ] up
so they don't actually like they make it
at the beginning of the day in the
morning okay and then when it like every
like hour or two they just they're just
like [ __ ] oh what that's at the end of
the day it's just like soup dude wow
you're not trying to get the wings yeah
all they do is just add water to it bro
well at least that's fine at least it's
just water
yeah but like dude it just it's it's
goop at the end of the day like water
like
11 a.m get the good [ __ ] yeah
before noon time you literally have to
go at like 11 a.m right before noon you
have to be a piece of [ __ ] to get a bowl
of wendy's chili's at 11 a.m or else
you're [ __ ]
damn someone's watching this with a bowl
of wendy's right now yeah there's a
problem
you're gonna [ __ ] your pants all right
you're gonna [ __ ] yourself
you already know what you did
[Music]
who the [ __ ] really goes to wendy's and
gets chilly though you know 900 thousand
[ __ ] people i guarantee you as a
child i guarantee you're pretty [ __ ]
up really [ __ ] heavy yeah i know sure
i know it
wow
but the dude the burgers and the fries
bang why would you need chili
because some [ __ ] just want to
eat [ __ ] out of a cup and that's why
there's frosties
in a cup dude crackers go hard too
saltine crackers are elite
there's some good snacks you like
no i don't like crackers unless i'm
dipping them uh
i don't i [ __ ] with the cracker
yeah this is a real conversation right
here this is a genuine [ __ ] cause i
know i heard crackers do that
immediately you got offended
offended
marty just [ __ ] gosh
i got party with me on this one so you
guys are going to stand on this show
stop shots man
should do another shot yeah did you hear
the gunshot too yeah yeah yeah i heard
that's it for sure you guys grew up in
nice neighborhoods man you guys grew up
in a nice day
yeah i grew up in the burbs type [ __ ]
i didn't grow up in any materials yeah i
was not in the cut or anything like that
you're lucky the chair didn't pray for
my movement so fast
could you imagine i snapped the [ __ ]
sheriff mid podcast we have one more but
damn
yo i found all these chairs
not at the same time by the way guys
what
that's crazy no way these are nice isn't
that cheers to you they are they're
almost identical
you [ __ ] jerk my heart's going crazy
i'm sweating now
hey what's up everybody welcome to our
mid-roll ad read if you're one of those
humans that take shits you could
probably use a tushy save about 80 on
your toilet paper cost right off the bat
which is a big plus it does not involve
insane installation you don't have to
call a plumber and pay him to come do it
nothing like that it's eco-friendly it
looks pretty cool to ask your toilet i'm
going to be just for me to you it looks
kind of awesome this is not going to run
up your bill it's the same water that's
running through your toilet already
nothing changes also from hello tushy
they have toilet ottomans i found out
about these about two years ago i didn't
realize it was a health thing i was like
why do you have foot stools by your
toilet my homie had it and i had to ask
apparently when you're sitting you put
your feet on it and it allows your
digestive tract to push everything out
nothing gets clogged but also besides
the tushy besides the bidet you can also
get the item and get the brush get
whatever you want check out their
website it's hellotushy.com forward
slash dope is 10 off plus free shipping
just try it i guarantee you on
everything sponsor or not you're not
gonna want to not have it you're gonna
need it smearing [ __ ] around your ass is
literally a thing in the [ __ ] past
but days are not new it's just something
that people feel a little awkward about
but what's more awkward walking around
with [ __ ] still in your ass or not
you saw i'm with marty on this one and
then you scared the death scared the
[ __ ] out of me you just get on his
shoulders
no one's wrong with you it's over
it's [ __ ] over
yo i had
oh my god
i was literally just about to it's been
20 minutes it's been [ __ ] 20 minutes
has it as i reach in the bag again god i
was just about to bring something oh
that's what it was what just lost it
again are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me would
you lose
the thought that i had in my head
got it
got it remind me taco bell lady
on fast food taco bell lady colorado
talk dick grab taco belly to colorado
all right oh what a story i tell you
guys
wait wait
just remember that so i don't forget
dick grab and taco bell [ __ ] gotta
write it down okay
just so we don't forget because i have
to tell you guys the story right after
it's [ __ ] incredible all right okay
amazing i hope you shouldn't work there
anymore because if you do
[ __ ] get ready [ __ ]
[Music]
is it a manager it's always the fast
food managers [ __ ]
i'll tell you i'll tell you
it's funny i have my hand on the same
thing
it's a blunt
one of the only blunts you ever can see
nice that's pretty cool
i like that okay what is it though oh
it's a hemp wrap oh
thank you because i don't know i don't
see anything saying about and you
couldn't sell it yeah it's not like that
where's our scissors yeah i can't find
the indent to to open this all right
please don't cut your hands off guys
i'll try my best to avoid it
sir there you go for everyone driving
i'm very sorry but there's a
a [ __ ] box cutter
being used for this blunt
hold on this is a joint
oh yeah hey
oh [ __ ] that's dope cool i mean it's a
swisher pack let's go get the skizzies
oh this one's got a knife oh wait what
did you say i didn't hear him say that
all right i apologize
that's like a useful last thing man you
never know what could happen out there
oh like that just so you don't cut
yourself
oh nice absolutely
knife you walk around with i gave it to
him for the seatbelt
oh [ __ ] oopsies oh can i just use it for
the seat belt is it just like oh i'm
gonna hurt myself huh yo we got a
dangerous time out here weed edibles no
more knives oh here it is
this thing looks nice
it looks very nice all right shout out
to dtpg for this all right big ups
presidential that's all it says it's got
key flower and distillate that's what it
says in there that's nice i think this
is going to really get us right we
should do another shot though before we
oh yeah that's what we're doing and then
you scared me to death it's a big straw
that's the score what's going
honestly we talked about it yeah we did
i i think i am going to do it because he
said i think i'm doing coke straws gold
coke straws that's fine and then what
does it say are the little capsules that
you hold with the attached little straw
right it's just fun [ __ ] but what did we
say it's gonna say no no we said him
like you will what if it said that [ __ ]
engraved and you said it
come on and we both
huh
save the turtles
stop using plastic straws thank you
that's amazing save the turtles that's
amazing
and the turtles should be walking with a
big like trail behind him
on one side of the turtle then on the
other side save the turtles cold plated
cocaine that's just beautiful i mean if
you're gonna do the merch already that's
amazing so thank you so much for
remembering that would have drove me
[ __ ] crazy dude i'm sorry that's nice
i forgot
no i was talking to emily i know but i'm
just okay yeah i i couldn't remember
either i'm apologizing on my behalf
you're good that's your shh
let me get you
thank you thank you all right so shots
sorry for everybody driving you're just
like what the [ __ ] happening don't
take shots if you're driving bad idea
yeah if you're trying to charge yourself
a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah you're kind
of an [ __ ] i don't even hang out with
you rap bastard
yeah i usually make fun of my homies i
should talk to mad [ __ ] when they would
drink and drive right i probably should
try to like stop them but [ __ ] i can't
really
hold somebody down i've hidden keys
that only works for so long so they get
upset that they can't wear their keys
okay
shot
joint
taco bell dick grab
yep all right yep ready
ready ding ding ding
cheers
that one's stung how was it yeah that
was it right
that would really hit was it just me
then that would go oh yeah
all right here we go now we got ready
now we got it yeah let's get it up
so i'm gonna do this story super quick
i was at a place in colorado if she
works there i don't care i don't give a
[ __ ]
this lady i talk about
it no it's corporate taco bell
so all right ready do you guys remember
fourth meal
when taco bell started doing fourth meal
uh 12 to something you get a big box for
this amount and they started the dollar
menu
i don't think i remember that no okay do
you remember when taco bell just started
doing [ __ ] for a dollar like a random
toast out of this a cheesy potato wrap
yeah so how much it was fire dude okay
so you remember when it happened right i
remember when it was on the menu i
remember when it first started right
okay well it started in like 2013 2012
maybe 14. okay i'm at this weed party
right i'm at the cannabis cup i'm not
the high times cannabis cup when it was
still fun
and we're at this everybody's yeah we're
at this thing like a party after like a
mingling type of networking party okay
and this girl is shit-faced
drunk
super cool super nice but she's drunk
turns out she works for taco bell
corporate she's the head of marketing
for taco bell so what she walks up she's
like yo i fall that's when i first
started like i'll follow you i love it
because she did this weed brand too her
boyfriend did
and
i'm like oh no [ __ ] she's like try it
out try it i'm like
you guys are doing the marketing for
taco bell and i told you like marketing
is what i always wanted to do because
make commercials and [ __ ]
and i thought damn this high-ass girl
drunk as [ __ ] is the head of marketing
of taco bell and she said the reason we
started the dollar menu in the fourth
meal is because we were trying to think
of how do we get more stoned ass kids to
come in and buy [ __ ] right because from
12 to two is when people are [ __ ] up
and they want weird dollar menu [ __ ] and
she's like and it worked and that's why
i still have my position she's telling
me all this crazy [ __ ]
and then about 25 minutes later that's
so dope yeah yeah the bathroom and this
girl tried to grab my dick
so dick grabbing taco bell and i went
hey hey hey hey i just met your
boyfriend
what the [ __ ] my homie tree jay
like 15 minutes ahead of taco bell
marketing grabbed your [ __ ]
that's
hey hey hey
i'm not done 15 minutes later
that white girl just grabbed my dick
oh man
her boyfriend she's like she's a groper
her boyfriend's bright dad strongest
never felt worse
the thing is when i first met her she
wasn't even [ __ ] shitfaced yet hours
into the part i'm like oh she's faded
faded but she's telling me all about the
mark she's like oh i've seen your videos
like you should start doing youtube like
yeah maybe once before i ever even made
an account no way yeah she's like oh
yeah maybe one day but i'm like really
into instagram
i was just doing instagram at the time
and um
yeah that [ __ ] grabbed my dick wow and
it was really funny i went and told rosa
hey that girl right
dick you're slipping that's a million
dollar check right there
yeah oh
[Music]
i can't do that
i can't do it
i can go hey i'm gonna tell everybody
you should just grab a dick if you don't
let me film some commercials or like you
know just pay me
[Laughter]
shout out to talk about if we can get to
make their commercials i guarantee you a
spike in sales
oh my gosh
come on bro fantastic like you haven't
seen
the sales with skye they would have
never had a commercial that effective
before yeah except the taco bell dog
because that was oh okay sure all the
dogs ones man target dog had a dog for a
minute oh yeah the uh the red eye or
they die a couple years ago yeah yeah
yeah yeah they just can't replace it you
know it's classic i like that i mean
it's hard to replace that dog you know
what i'm saying like when you make a dog
your mascot you kind of set yourself up
you know yeah i would just get another
dog that [ __ ] think it's just
not the same
same
dudes with binoculars you know that
ain't the same dog
like trust me it [ __ ] is
what oh yeah so talk about dick grabber
and
the lady that does the taco bell we used
to oh i hope i don't get her in trouble
i don't give a [ __ ] the lady used to
talk about was a [ __ ] pothead which
really made me smile like wow
nice you're appealing to the people you
know is like
whoa a dollar for that
holy [ __ ]
i wonder what the corporate world's
looking like for weed probably still
[ __ ] huh in terms of like yeah
corporate [ __ ] um it's just regular
dudes and flip-flops
and every dude out there right now on
their [ __ ] expensive car wit
cannabis company yeah you're wearing the
rainbow one the one that says rainbow
that's you
that's pretty much all really rich dudes
that invest in weed [ __ ]
just [ __ ] flip-flopping it
that's all right it's like a lot of rich
people i feel like have you ever seen a
i think it's like an old like car
salesman kind of thing it's like car
smells been at really really like
high-end dealerships um with the kids
that come in like there's people that
come in like in these nice suits and
it's like freshly pressed and they know
they're not gonna buy anything they're
just gonna like walk around but the
people that coming in like a hoodie and
like flip-flops are like this guy's
gonna buy like two or some [ __ ] like
that's like you know when you get to
like not give a [ __ ] well they're like
oh you can just like tell
like these like car salesmen
i guess that's cool we used to sell cars
did you ever
i didn't like i wasn't like directly a
car salesman but i know but did you
think like that oh make sure you talk to
him like oh this guy's not gonna buy
this guy i am working with some super
luxury dealers right i worked at a lexus
dealership so it wasn't like you know
hello issues are coming in but they were
like you know
50k 40k
you know it's still a cheapest [ __ ] for
a luxury car
it's still a luxury car
yeah that's right yeah 100
and merced you know there's crazy
gangsters if it's green with the gold
emblems
you know those lexuses with the green or
the camrys and lexuses it was like the
old 90s or early 2000s they're green you
guys know about yeah it's like gold em
you know someone's got a gun in that car
that's what you know and it's [ __ ] up
on one part of the car said lego here
can you have a gun in your car here in
cali [ __ ] no wow that's so oh cause in
texas you can 100
your car is controlled you can roll with
a gun loaded yeah
maybe you can't be loaded one in the
chamber but you can have a gun in your
car it's considered like a part of your
[Music]
uh you need a concealed license but they
just made like a state amendment the
governor was like anyone can carry a gun
on them what but you have to show it you
have to like have like you don't need a
license to carry a gun but oh but it has
to be like you have like an open like
open carry license
put it on your person at all times you
do need a license to have a gun but as
long as you can see it right right so
you do need a license to have a gun but
once you get that license you can carry
it on your person at all times
i need that i need that [ __ ] heavy but
the concealed one you still have to go
to a class for but it's worth it for
circus like you don't want to and i feel
like that's like attention grab you know
when i like walk into a place and
you know what i don't want to get on my
hip yeah for sure
i want to martin lawrence my gun
[Music]
oversized button up you know
you can't just walk in with a strap on
you because anyone who wants to do
something to you
knows what you have right where it is
you're the first one that's so yeah
you're [ __ ] yeah private businesses
and stuff can still reject like bars and
stuff will be like you can't have that
in here you know what i mean yeah yeah
texas sounds kind of tight texas is cool
bro texas is dope there's probably not
as many shootouts because people like
you probably gotta go yeah yeah
everyone's like you know what i mean
like you just assume people like your
people shoot you in traffic
yeah
it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] yo
who was i with
when we talked about it was that with
you when we talked about
apparently some fool at shoe palace it
was a shoe pal oh yeah
[Music]
like it was a raffle um sort of where
you like the people are lined up and
only certain people win or something and
then there was a fight over the raffle
outside and this guy was just walking by
and tried to like break it up so it
wasn't even like i don't even think he
was a shoe palace employee it just
happened like because of like not
because of shoe palace that sounds crazy
but i mean like the raffle and the
raffle disagreement fight yeah he was
just trying to break up the fight like
he wasn't even involved like i don't
think he had a like a piece in the shoot
he was just trying to that guy
dude i don't know oh man like there's
some [ __ ] pop crazy yeah dude killed him
crazy stuff in the middle of the street
it was like [ __ ] noon noon on melrose
and now a mil on melrose in the day yeah
melrose avenue in the day it was like a
week ago it's [ __ ] up all right
[ __ ] yeah that's so shitty
oh
stupid stupid [ __ ]
oh
i mean it depends it depends on what's
going on i'd be like yo yo i got some
i've broken up a fight with weed before
yeah i'll tell you that in like denver
denver airport enterprise oh
yeah there was about to be a fight i
could see it happening and these friends
are about to kill each other and i was
like yeah yeah
here's some weed and they all like
jumped into the sky like no way so i can
overhear him because i was renting a car
you know what i'm saying right it takes
and i can hear these fools like i walked
in like oh
these folks are gonna fight and then as
i hear the conversation like all their
friends oh you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
and now you're all stuck here now all
these guys are mad at you
then this falls on your side and now
they're mad at you and the friend that
got stuck was like have the weight have
the person at enterprise see if they can
take us and get some weed
you're gonna ask somebody at work at
enterprise like yo could you drive me a
dispensary
[ __ ] no how weird right
yeah that's why they were yelling like
that's hilarious [ __ ] up we're not gonna
do that
and then i went to my suitcase and i had
my i always duct taped my jar lids
because little [ __ ] tsa fools will
pull nugs out so i duct tape my jar
let's shut when i travel a weed
and um
i went in i got it and i gave him some
fire and i literally handed it to the
guy and all of them crowded around like
it's like a movie scene he opened his
hand and they all no
nobody was mad no more everybody was
hella happy it was cool later that night
walked to the lobby my hotel [ __ ] up
and all of them were right there staying
on my same [ __ ] floor as i don't know
stay in the same hotel on the same floor
five years later i'm sitting at [ __ ]
rainbow room with one of my friends and
he brings his homies from the east coast
and i'm looking at this guy i'm like
looking for man familiar
and the guy looks at me he's like yo you
look mad familiar no way all right no
way i don't know where i met you
and he goes
denver colorado enterprise goal you're
the homie that was going to beat the
share that guy goes
that was him and they were like all
friends still and i only recognized the
one dude
i know the guy now he has really good
hash nice no way yeah like it turned out
like really [ __ ] cool yeah yeah
that's awesome that's the only time we'd
like it stopped the fight
yeah we solved a lot of things man
weight solves a lot of problems that's
why it's illegal it was like that like
if you guys are gonna kill each other
[Music]
and you guys stopped that's how it felt
that's the way to do it bro it's 200 it
was [ __ ] awesome i tip a lot of my um
my ubers and lifts and everything in my
door dash and [ __ ] away they're like
super hyped about it they're way more
hyped than what they're like
you know what i mean they're like give
them an edible and they're like oh bro
yeah
sometimes you get that one oh no i don't
smoke weed
oh i know and i'm now i feel like a
piece of [ __ ] i know no trying to push
this on you and [ __ ] us the worst have
you ever tried to give a bum weed and
they say no
no i don't think so have you they take
that [ __ ] no not really i usually give
them beer oh you told me about that yeah
if i give you have you ever said no no
like when i nowadays like
uh some of the homeless people in my
town are really like aggressive like
don't come to your car like catch my
window i don't [ __ ] when they do that oh
it's crazy where do you live again uh i
live in like a pretty rural part of
illinois okay gotcha it's just not like
midwest crackheads and [ __ ] yeah like
matt like yeah good math tweakers oh
yeah they smell good tina
no break it down christina crystal i
don't know bro
i've heard people like chris christina
yeah i've heard people using illinois in
general i just want to know where it
came i love different slangs bro it's
cool like in pittsburgh
you're from there
uh you're gonna buy a fifth
fifth when people say fifth as trash
weed
oh no smoke's fifth
fif i've never heard that justin boyd
from pittsburgh
bro cut up
full like y'all this was mad cut up what
does that sound like to you like oh that
fool's buff
yeah i guess yeah
cut up means like you're a goofy [ __ ] oh
oh whoa
like yo this one's cut up like bro are
you hitting on me
like i know i've been lifting
that's that's what i hear like right
right shut up bro what the [ __ ] yeah the
slangs everywhere you know they made
that [ __ ] up chop it up and merced mean
suck my dick
whoa
girl like oh she chopped me up like
and she helped me out man
oh and then i went to the band like yo
i'm hungry we're just chopping it
but in the bay it's open everywhere else
but merced it means let's have a
conversation chop it up yeah yeah yeah
yeah
let's grab it
but it's
in middle school when i went to middle
school chop it up means some girl sucked
your dick and i go oh that's that's
weird
and then i heard chop it up when i was
older and in the bay i went oh damn did
you ever hear it and at first think like
people were like like did you at first
interpret it the wrong way
of course what does that mean a girl
chopped you i go that sounds
ah
i'm trying to think
nope don't have any any explanations for
that one no experience so from the
[ __ ] adapt
yeah because i love different slang i
know you got some wild ass lame from new
york
oh marty's got the good new york slay
no we got our
people here in new york and think new
york city like i said we're more canada
than new york city
okay so you say a
no
well you they actually like yeah it's
that deep nasally a like
canada is
slaying a spanish and canadian slang
what's up eh yeah but he was all choloed
out that's exactly what that was about
realize that
yeah that's hilarious canadians sound
like people from
east l.a
hey what's up hey like yo that's exactly
what canadian dudes sound like at least
that i've seen i don't know you're naked
okay you guys are you've been to canada
no
canadian guys oh yeah i heard your
canister that was an accident yeah yeah
yeah never mind
you know this joint not bad i heard
canada wait have you lived in canada no
no yeah yeah i had a homie who um lived
in detroit so that's not too far from i
think it's toronto or something like a
couple hour drive so
between the ages of like 19 and 21
because you ought to be 19 in canada
smoke drink do anything right yeah so
it's like a two year difference so him
and his homies would just cross the
border real quick like and just chill in
toronto for a little bit yeah thing
right right and he told me he was like
the best way to describe canada it's
like you ever seen like a bollywood
movie he's like yeah he's like it's like
a bollywood america it's like a kind of
just like a goofy like a grade b america
and i was like i guess that kind of
makes sense it's like
that's so funny it's like a little like
[ __ ] right i was like okay that makes
sense have you ever sat and actually
watched something bollywood [ __ ] yeah
like more than 50
more than 15 minutes it was
unbelievable me rose you read an indian
restaurant
and some of these dudes are like
superman and michael jackson over there
like they're all buff and doing crazy
[ __ ] and singing all high pitched and
there's bombs going off and they're
walking on like [ __ ] elephants
shaking like yo is this full like super
popular
and they're super popular
[ __ ] yeah it's so odd it's the oddest
[ __ ] i mean it's [ __ ] crazy bro i
don't know i mean like everyone's doing
a secret nice dance in every single shot
it's like the same movie over and over
it's tight i was like yo this makes me
feel like oh
all hyped up it was a good vibe but it's
like
how do you differentiate you know what
dance i really liked
the one where they were in the green and
they went like this
no i like the one where they were in red
and they went like that like what the
[ __ ] was it i kept seeing the same clips
from different shits i wasn't i was on
music videos
so i'm like watching the pop stars over
there
those fools are popping oh for sure
they're bopping heavy over there i love
it
you gotta put me on some of these i
don't know any names
i couldn't tell you one [ __ ] name
they were just seeing [ __ ] i was no i
was at a restaurant and they were just
looking like the mtv of [ __ ] india oh
yeah it was all the bollywood like damn
the top stars
and oddly k-pop was in it too k-pop's
crazy they were like k-pop oh somebody
even [ __ ] oh let's throw a korean one in
there like oh odd choice
for the bollywood restaurant i can't get
into like
i don't listen to it for like yeah i
understand you know like yeah no i'm not
saying like that i just was hyped while
i was even like this is crazy i have to
be [ __ ] up and then i can get into
anything nice
you're close i have to be really good
you're you're close
let's take some more shots 140 right
we're good
yeah 40 water nice reach into the bag
you're up oh i'm up
oh i love this
this is fantastic this is a great idea
you had you the every 20 minute thing
nice brilliant great
eric have you ever acted before like
besides the flower company thing i know
you did that cool thing that was like a
cool little thing though that's like
kind of acting
nice that's different what kind of so
fun they're commercial commercial like
two years ago and it was super sick
that's so dumb yeah but i've never done
anything it was fun bro it was
we got a lot of [ __ ] on the first take
right nice because i was so scared
thinking there's 30 [ __ ] people
working
i i'm gonna say you're like this high
kid can't even say the lie so i was like
really [ __ ] on it you know what i
mean
little punch bar edible
and mine is the same thing again because
there was no chocolate i feel that i
feel that shout out to punch bar
i never tried those
they're pretty cool i've never tried
this either
they used to be uh i think they used to
be like 300 milligrams each and then
they got all licensed and now they had
that i remember they had a thousand
milligram one yeah
used to have a thousand milligram black
bar remember the black pepper
[Music]
just these laws man you hear about like
how oklahoma has like some crazy laws
like no limit on like oh man moved there
last year yeah it was like i gotta hold
me that means
and that's what he's doing he's got lead
right right shut up people are described
as like the wild wild west that's
exactly exactly what the [ __ ] he said
yeah wild wild west out here that's
exactly what he said
holy [ __ ] that's what i'm hearing man
what's that oh it's a gummy dude this
[ __ ] i wasn't i thought it was gonna be
a chocolate i thought it was chocolate i
think ours is oh ours is a gummy never
mind hey
there we go
do it let's do it
you're one month free off narcotics it's
amazing yep did you have a bad week
uh the first week
it was a little
ugly yeah
i mean i don't know i've been kind of uh
doing a lot of [ __ ] this summer you know
traveling a good bit
uh
having some fun you know
but i've just been smoking more weed and
that's been helping but my tolerance is
getting to a point where like that's
also you need to i gotta i gotta smoke a
lot yeah
and the [ __ ] in illinois is just so
different than the [ __ ] here like right
just leagues away yeah turn your mic
towards you a little
right there
way better perfect yeah nice
but um
no like it's just the the weed no noise
just leaks away
like it's not comparable
it's crazy so if you smoke this
stupid right have you seen these prices
for illinois weed bro oh i call the
dispensary on stream because i'll say yo
is this even real and uh hall dispense
with me while on stream yeah yeah yeah
i was like yeah there's no way right but
it was um
it was like forty five dollars fifty
dollars for a point three of distillate
and i was like wait how much are like
the full grams oh
like 140 yeah
for a cartridge damn
yeah and the eights are like kind of
similar over here like 70 i guess
whatever like that's just kind of
[ __ ] kidding me dude disgusting
prices is all horrible like horrible
prices that would make you sick
if if the dispo prices over here are
pretty gross i have a medical card and
it still isn't
like most of the time
wait i can't show a pound of weed
unfortunately not on here i thought well
you guys know i finally got a pound
today i've been buying it's good weed
but i've been buying dispensary weed
right for about seven months
just a lot of apes
i've been flying through eights it adds
up bro bro
adds up because that's a horrible thing
it's this
you know that's exactly what it is what
the [ __ ] am i talking about i could have
bought more for less and both that's
exactly what time it's been adding up i
could have just got it for half [ __ ]
price if i just bought it yeah
no one's had any pounds worth buying
right and i wasn't gonna bring the
[ __ ] company or grower name up
because i do not support that because of
the price
yeah but there's a black market company
out here
you probably know what it is but we
won't say it they sell gelato another
strain and an og
can you take a guess on how much this
black market pack is
in california in
2021
2021
just in case
i [ __ ] up and you guys didn't
understand that
price of a pack price for one pound in
this [ __ ] state right now in real
time us dollars
just just just and people it's selling
out within 15 minutes
how
like for the pack just
high quality is it the most fire og i've
ever smoked oh wow
but but there's been like the most fire
rj ever smoked
back a little there's like a number two
that's real close to that yeah and the
number three four five and six like
it's right here
but there's other ones right here and
they're not that much like you know what
i'm trying to say like three three and a
half bands
no think higher i think
four for the pack
i'll give you guys one more guess no
seven one more
there's no way
yeah right okay yeah i'm guessing too
high i guess 5k eight
and then the other strain the color
ten or nine five
for the p for the pound 448 grams
448 grams bro
this element zips at one spot
because it's a legal spot right
they did the deal they've ever done
guess how much it was because it was for
two zips now take a guess how much it
was for two zips retail
like
take one guess okay one against each
other i think five way away two zip two
ounces only okay okay okay it was
definitely over a thousand dollars
yeah yeah i guess anything about it
because like damn no way what 10k i just
want to hear your guess i'll take one
solid guess this is the prices i say a
rack
that's 15.80
and my homie showed me the receipt now
when you bought this awesome no he said
but off a zip that he just bought for
somebody real quick to make two hundred
dollars of an ounce is insane
real quick 700 ounces just at once
especially two years you gotta bring it
down by like you can upsell that
challenge because you want two
no he only sold one
and he smoked the other one so he got a
deal on him for
it's like new york [ __ ] do i sound like
in new york really turtles you can't tax
me this is not the state
my homie sounds like a ninja turtle from
he's from
the bro
sounds like a ninja turtle for sure i
love that [ __ ] accent it's my
favorite bro yeah you don't have it at
all that's what i'm saying it's not the
same thing at all i mean not everyone
sounds like a ninja turtle that's a gift
that's a blessing bro but there's a
certain new york accent that everybody
sounds like ninja turtles
you know what i'm saying that generic
one yeah i only know new york from home
alone and [ __ ] yeah yeah everyone and
ninja turtles i watched the departed
which is i rewatched the departed which
is like boston yo i just i just watched
it for the first time ever all the way
through no way what a solid ass movie
well i've never seen
that
it's a good movie
so they talk about them well when it
came out i was going to night school
because i was in trouble and senior year
it came out here
and i walked home from night school
because nobody answered my i guess i'll
walk through the [ __ ] gang
land you [ __ ] i'm fine i might wear red
blue i walk in and i just see we won't
say to ruin it but one of the main
characters that gets [ __ ] murdered at
the end right oh yeah yeah that's every
movie so i won't really cherish you yeah
right when i walked in i saw him get
shot in the face and went
all this that new movie oh
so i'm not watching this movie ever i
just watched during quarantine for the
first time hell yeah because i'm like
you know i need to give some time and
then i forgot about it for 12 years
and then i watched it it was all right
yeah the best score stacey martin square
for me for sure but it was cool leonardo
caprio is the [ __ ] the man good guy
that's awesome fantastic
cool this guy's pretty good i just see
mark wahlberg matt damon and uh
the good guys
and ted that's all i can say is
like a funny guy a funny guy he's kind
of funny in that movie though he's
always saying something [ __ ] in that
movie yeah yeah in the party yeah yeah
party's good man um
so we're over here reviewing old ass
movies have you guys how you guys
feeling let's go yes i just like movies
i'm a movie guy you like you like tv
shows or movies i watch a good amount of
movies i really watch that many shows
right
it's just so much more time committing
it just kind of depends on like what i'm
doing that day like if i got time to
watch a movie i'll watch a movie
favorite three movies
top right now go
good fellas number one uh i i don't know
oh it's in there no no just just go i
think i'll just do a general time right
right good fellas good fellas for sure
mine hasn't changed in a minute i'll
give you some time it's just kind of
tough because like
sometimes i watch different movies and
it updates you know well you you leave
comedies out because comedy is is its
own category it's too hard to not throw
comments yeah yeah yeah okay just other
movies that aren't comedy um
i really like 28 weeks later better than
how many days later actually in the
movie
um i'm just gonna lay it out
actually
like 28 weeks he likes anxiety is what
he said i like thrillers i'm scared
movies are great that's the ultimate
zombie movie they spread in full speed i
am legend they're sprinting too it's
great
it is kind of it's scary
like crazy is it like world war iii
they're climbing over that [ __ ] wall
all they get that's crazy they go crazy
damn what your third movie that'd be
cool oh
okay
potentially scarface just because
it's not ever a bad choice i've just
done a lot of load of that
like like a really good guy something to
have in the background you know good
time good times great move you got to
remember that little cuban
is also the fool from
goodfellas and he's also the man from
son of a woman
and [ __ ] the devil's advocate you got
to remember this man played so many
people that's right you're not cuban i
forgot
i think it's tony montana acting
he said oh he's his own guy dude's real
name yeah you forget that it's a
different guy you're like you expected
like tony montana to pop yeah
that's when you win oscars which you
should have but he didn't yeah
that's when you're at cult classics
right that's so petty that he didn't he
that's [ __ ] that was great bro he did
[ __ ] yes look at him godfather and go
yo you're gonna play like wow cubans
norton cult and kill him
all right [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna watch card
face tonight i dedicate three hours
tonight
maybe tomorrow
yeah yeah yeah i gotta add it but maybe
tomorrow i'm gonna watch scarface i
haven't seen it in a couple years it's a
good one
100 such a good movie
yeah three movies go uh first one's
saving private ryan
as soon as he was yelling for his mom
with his guts out i was a kid that was a
movie man the whole movie was insane i
can't watch great movies
later that's a sad movie for sure for
sure
probably
the dark knight
that's a fire movie
i only like uh michael keaton batman's
really no way ah the old man
it's a different time
yeah yeah just as like a movie like not
even a superhero movie i just don't like
the voice change
christian bale man
dude he does some crazy movies hey man
what's up no nothing looking for this
guy where are you like what the heck
but then again
if batman did that to change his voice
which he should have yeah
then he's the best batman right yeah
if it if it's like that cause i never
wrote comic books and [ __ ] the [ __ ] yeah
i i tried when i was a kid but i just
can't i couldn't do it get into it but
the dark knight was a good ass movie
yeah i like it i just like knowledge i
think i think nolan's my favorite
director
or like sports yes he's probably up
there like
christopher nolan just makes some great
movies um but that was a good ass movie
[ __ ] yeah that's not the one with bane
right no that's dark night returns
[Music]
the latest joker movie wasn't that great
honestly it was okay yeah it was good it
was like it's not something i'd ever
rewatch you know i watch it again just
to see like all right they did a good
job they did a good job but yeah it
wasn't like what you were expecting for
sure yeah i just feel they could have
done so much more with it right it was
the back story and it was like all artsy
and sad they drew out the story too slow
and they made it end really abruptly
that's the leading factor right when i
thought oh hell yeah it's going to get
exciting here yeah you stab this
[ __ ]
yeah oh it's
over yeah yeah i get you you ever seen
taxi driver it's pretty much just taxi
driver it's like reskin taxi driver taxi
driver is really good with jody foster
and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah taste driver is
really good dude
um you ever seen mean streets no oh okay
it's around the same time it's a marty
scorsese movie yeah but it's when the
these [ __ ] like harvey cartel and
they're mad young it's like a
independent martin score stacy shot oh
trash lighting marty the lighting was
dog [ __ ]
that's how you know it was like that
first independent [ __ ] nice and it's
cool robert de niro played the side
character and harvey cartel played the
main so they thought like he was going
to be the take off and
i mean they're both really big actors
but like obviously robert took over yeah
yeah three decades
right
yeah
but um
those are great [ __ ] picks thanks man
there's [ __ ] like some movies like-wise
what are your chapters
yeah
um it's always a tie between truman
shore or forrest gump for first but one
and two and then uh american beauty is
my third one okay but now that kevin's
space is getting a little rapey
i might have to change that just because
but then again
i'm just watching i'm just watching the
[ __ ] movie i like yeah i mean i like
that movie i
i can't like it
yeah smuggled two zips in an american
beauty double disc uh
cassette case in the airport when i was
like
well out of what airport
sacramento to portland how did you feel
i just put it in the case
which right in there yeah i mean i
triple bagged it and taped taped it
i always felt like the tape nice keeps
smelling
did you check the bag
did you know that was my carry-on oh
nice yeah i always do it they still
searched me they searched me though
but they didn't find it they stopped
right but it's a long story but anyway i
always [ __ ] my pants and threw up at the
same time
my dad's standing right next to me i
almost [ __ ] threw up my god and then
i almost almost ran but we're gonna run
to the airport
but what do you think like oh stand take
it [ __ ] no you'll probably escape
somebody's gonna have to [ __ ] jump on
that bro get my id my dad but you're not
going to find me for days wow
even though i'm not from youtube you're
going to hide in the [ __ ] woods or
some [ __ ] they're going to come to your
house that same day that's fine
nice yo you know the best way to get out
of a bad situation just sprint as fast
as you can away because when you're
running you can think
circle back circle back
just sprint away like caught in the line
ah it take off
i've done it many times i did so much as
a kid just right it's a smart play yes
it's my play i mean
it's funny it gives you time it makes me
laugh realistically like the amount of
trouble you get in for just having it at
the airport is so [ __ ] yeah and i was
a kid
yeah you're probably [ __ ] brakes
it's not like i was gonna [ __ ] but you
know when you're like clench like oh if
i [ __ ] my pants it's getting out
vividly yeah i definitely locked my
knees
for sure i definitely thought [ __ ] was
coming out of my pants
this one is you get that like remember
that mic situation we had earlier
that you ever get that in your stomach
right before you throw up oh that's what
it sounded like that's why i was driving
crazy 100 that's what i got definitely
when i was walking over so i'm gonna
search your bag i'm a kid
under the blue stripe shirt man she
didn't go under that shit's ready
it's all right but uh you know what's
not petty what
being 20 minutes later
all right i'm going to be honest the
joint was not bad at all it was cool
i'm stoned i'm not sure
marty's never heard dmx before but um
you guys ever heard of dmx yeah yeah
yeah
i'm just kidding it's the same guy
i don't know i just i watched belly you
ever seen the movie belly oh i finally
watched it because he's been like
telling me it's cinematic masterpiece oh
good it was really good
it was good what do you consider
cinematic masterpiece do you think would
you say like uh that movie uh
[ __ ] oh that movie that just came out
last year
um the war movie from 1928 1917 1917 oh
yeah that's a good movie that's a good
movie yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that first shot was the greatest
oh we talked about this the opening
shot's about 15 minutes long oh and it's
one [ __ ] take
and no one [ __ ] up it's crazy and
they're walking through i bet they did
it a lot of times but i mean it's
for three months straight and then they
shot that because the explosions they
ran through the scene in a couple months
right because there's like 50 moving
parts yeah
if you [ __ ] up that's expensive
everything's going off around because
they're in a trench in world war one and
the guy starts off hey hello it's like a
call of duty intro scene but it's all
one taking because you're following
these guys and as they're walking
boom boom [ __ ] feels like you're with
them it's really exciting and i was
waiting to see where the cut was and the
cut was when they're going through the
bob wearing mud i [ __ ] saw a split
second when they passed the bar right
and you can see this
a slide that's wild
where they weren't the same i love those
shots oh there's the cut so cool
if you were involved in movies do you
think you would like act or like produce
or like it don't matter
you're just doing that dude especially
after that [ __ ] commercial that i did
we're talking about right right it's so
[ __ ] sick everything about it yo i'm
gonna need this uh higher and these guys
went and moved a whole front of a house
the whole front accents of the house
they took them apart
change them and replace them
how big was that crew if you needed like
30 something people okay damn that's
yeah
bro they had a rain machine out and [ __ ]
and i'm over here smoking a [ __ ]
joint and thinking yo if i [ __ ] up all
these fools gonna be pissed
because they're like intimidating
i wasn't nervous i mean i was nervous i
wasn't intimidated okay it was scary
though gosh you got you definitely was
scary yeah yeah but the mic the mic guy
that foot was so close to my face
every time he changed my [ __ ] it did
this
did you have like a clip
you're like face
was he holding some [ __ ] to you yeah he
had a big boom mic um the guys that
stand there the guy stood there for
about seven [ __ ] hours how they do
that they right
that's insane unbelievable
the guy was just doing this holding that
dude's got that's a job
did you just make a coffee yes
and as the lady is doing my makeup i
find out she's from five miles from
where i'm from oh wow she's [ __ ] out
and from her touching and i say
something where did you just say well
what did you just say she was cool as
[ __ ] and stuff but yeah it was really
fun it really made me think like yeah
this is something i wanted like
somewhere in the future 100 that's
awesome we had a taco bell commercial
yeah you know what i'm saying we could
be fresh bro you know how mcdonald's is
doing those combo meals that are just
trash yeah
like we can get taco bell ones that are
good you know right right and make them
fun and funny as [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
and do a series of these this is all
i've ever wanted to do in my life right
we can have a show for sure i mean
you might have netflix throws money it's
stupid it's a party with that head of
marketing and like you see what [ __ ]
shows netflix
[Laughter]
good [ __ ]
meet me in room 16.
and and there's just some dudes to make
her sign the contract you know let's
just stop let's stop let's smoke this
i'm this is dumb i'm over here talking
about unrealistic [ __ ] are you guys
ready no it's not realistic it's gonna
happen for sure oh there's two joints in
these you guys smoking both at the same
time oh say so i'm down
and we ramble for five five minutes so
we only have a few minutes left uh uh
it's this wait i can't find no tube
action yeah a little
joint tubing
oh wait guys it's been 12 hours we've
been filming
whoa
all day bro you're the craziest grinder
out there i'm just waiting to see his
face
didn't even hear me
wait it's been what now
um you can't find this for real yeah i'm
actually is it in your hand right now
no i'm looking at the show i think it is
or is it this fire thing no i think it's
the other one man this is that's fine
they're cool
i don't think this yeah that's not it
that's not it i'm sorry
oh my bad
what's up guys just want to take a
minute to talk about one of our sponsors
this is on it and you guys already know
how excited marty and i to have this
sponsorship this is something we've been
working on since we started quick recap
in case you don't know what on it is
this is human optimization brand this is
for fitness this is every single thing
about being healthy being in shape for
your mind as well as your body that's on
it you see the mct oil you see the whey
protein but they have shroom check new
mood health boost they have so much
stuff alpha brain which i am currently
taking right now for focus and mood
boosting you guys there's it's
everything mental health is just as
important as physical so that's why i
tried the alpha brain and so far i like
it so if you're like me going through a
website picking everything wondering
what you want to try trying this trial
and error i i where's the variety pack
set that's what i want all right i want
to try a little bit of everything so on
it offers something called total human
it's a night and day pack it's it's for
everyone that needs to be on a schedule
that needs the discipline of like oh
what time is it let me take that what
time is it let me take that so you guys
already know i've been going hard lately
i'm really trying to like i said i'm
trying not to be fat anymore i'm this is
really helping this came at a perfect
time the weights the supplements
everything is just helping me be more
healthy if one percent of your brain is
interested in any of this just try it
try if you don't like it you don't have
to get it again but at least try it
maybe there's a new
mood there's a new life you could be
starting just with your brain and your
body being more healthy so if you're
interested at all guys go to onit.com
that's onnit.com
onit.com forward slash yolo that's 10
off of all supplements all gear have a
dope as day
hey we're back man it's good we're
starting a little [ __ ] up here uh
triple infused two joints keef outside
keef and oil inside damn
door flowers he's dripping
that [ __ ] be dripping all right let's
see absolutely bonkers
all right let's see let's oh i see
they're littles
they smile yeah it says point two point
sevens interesting what a random ass
numbered you know what give me
give us two point seven
you know
that's fire
interesting little lucky number maybe
oh no let's light one up and take a shot
yeah oh
oh oh oh let's do this let's do this
nice
they're compact a little bit though
all right
here we go here we go
oh it's lighting up there it is
yeah youtube's about to hate us
yeah they're not a fan of this they're
gonna hate that's all right
let's [ __ ]
get susan on the podcast one day
i'm so happy you said that crazy susan
come hang out and see that we're nice
kids come on suzy wash
nice people like we're we're good adults
100 percent responsible drugs
we promote youtube in a positive life in
a super stoked way yeah
yep
guys
susan is the lady was the president of
youtube no she still she is she's the
ceo of youtube okay she just signed the
little plaque thing that's the only
reason i know that name
susan something's other thing and she
always gives you the little
you know
email blasts right
that's fire
i wish they would give me my plaque they
just refused that'd be awesome
they never gave me money either i i
never will
you're never gonna on your main yeah you
gotta
i don't know yeah dude you have a second
have you ever thought about doing other
videos like weed videos and [ __ ] nah
yeah i made a second channel that i'm
starting pretty soon nice
good [ __ ] what's that going to be yeah
what's that you can let it be known
just smoking a bunch of wheat on camera
and [ __ ] did you make the name and [ __ ]
already uh
i'm not well it's called goblin 420 nice
like i don't know if it's
i don't know you know we'll see that's
clean just short as possible simple easy
100
100
um
i'll figure it out
uh but yeah i just want to do stupid ass
[ __ ] like i wanted to roll like a
an extend though but roll it as long as
like i possibly could to the point where
like like 10 swishers
10 is where it's like hold it all funny
like multiple people yeah it's like 10
years
on the other end
oh yeah at least at least yeah yeah
that's gonna be cool like i don't know
just some dumb [ __ ] like that because i
feel like you know
everyone's done like challenges and [ __ ]
you know that's kind of that's i feel
like that's fairly drawn out but doing
dumb [ __ ] like that you're a wild [ __ ]
yeah
yeah it's just more entertaining you
know
random weird [ __ ] is the only thing
because
there's only so many challenges you
could do man yeah
it's not all about challenges
but like smoking some [ __ ] that's fine
yeah yeah yeah 100 makes it better yeah
true
um so since you've been out here have
you been switching up your [ __ ]
doing different style because you mean
now you're in a legal state oh yeah yeah
i've been doing a lot more like vlog
content which has been dope like showing
because it was before it was like 99 of
my videos were me and my apartment so i
just had to find like different angles
in my place i was like i'm in the
kitchen now i'm in the living room but
it was like we like the same exact [ __ ]
because i couldn't show any roads any
restaurants any like anything this would
be instantly texas like texas has just
like this look about it all right you
know it's not cali you know what i mean
or you know it's not arizona where i
said i was so it was just like i was in
my apartment all the time just doing
like reviews stories or whatever but now
it's like vlogs i'm out there like going
to like events or like those sessions or
like you know i mean the dinners and
dabs or like whatever like it's been
dope nice cool the content's been cool
for sure like people it looks like
they're appreciating anything else so
you've been going to weed events right
like the pop-ups yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're pretty cool man they're
pretty cool
i don't think i have no
which ones are you going to like the la
ones the underground ones right yeah
yeah where you get like the instagram
like flyer dms type [ __ ] and usually
exactly they'll be like hey come to our
session tonight pounds are 16.
and then some guy will be there with 400
pounds just on a table yep hey a little
bit underground like 20 pounds of room
seriously like a little bit crazy people
start [ __ ] streams of these sessions
with just bags and bags and bags and
bags that sounds like why can't i please
concentrate you want to buy it i just
kind of always bought wheat off like my
friends you know who always had it like
it just
i i got all that [ __ ] off my homies i
never really like uh
a ton of people who went to those shows
and the the few people i did i don't
know didn't hang out with enough to like
go with them you know yeah the ones out
here get wild
the ones out here get hella crazy right
dude all the food trucks are dope too
this is a good energy guy that's the
only part of the the really happening
where chicago chicago oh no i uh shout
out to [ __ ]
fernando um
there's chicago weed scene
yeah chicago has pretty good weed dude
like it's not bad i feel like if you're
a big city you have weed like even if
you're in the legal state or and i know
it's legal now for the most part yeah
cause i know how the places in florida
had good like have good weed and you
know it's shipped out though right right
right yeah yeah i think i've read some
stat or it's like 80 90 percent of the
weed in the country's from cali like
whether it's outdoor or like you know
brilliant but like yeah it's all like
moved packed shipped somewhere you know
what i mean really yeah so all the fire
used to get texas was had to be some
california weed for sure 100 it wasn't
even like a doubt really yeah yeah how
about colorado you're so close
i mean maybe colorado i don't know
though it's like great
it's great mids which is really weird
they have good concentrates and like
really good mids which is weird to say
yeah i mean i don't know what if you're
born on a budget i think it's like
colorado you know it's like some signs
or something actually like the elevation
or something because it's so high to the
sun or something but their weed is cheap
it's like a 120 an ounce and it's like
pretty like it's
good it's like i shouldn't say but it's
like it's trash compared to cali though
if you compare it it's really dry it's
really really dry 100 something like
that just drop it on the table it'll
just shreds yeah it's crazy or just like
you can crunch it you know just like it
goes insane bro it's so dry it's so dry
that's so great it'll turn your weed
like that bring another wheat out there
it just dries your weed out
i have no idea but the hash is [ __ ]
fire colorado's got some great hash
games stupid ass good glass game as well
yes
i love it out there i just didn't like
driving there's dog [ __ ] you drove here
from here
yeah
what's that driving like we drove
because i drove from texas and it was
like 40.
it's scary driving in the snow is it's
[ __ ] i don't [ __ ] with that driving in
the snow is sick i mean i'm from
illinois so i'm kind of used to it it
smells really bad
yeah but you hella snow where are you
from illinois yeah in the winter you
gotta like shovel and [ __ ] kind of bad
yeah driveway oh yeah oh hell no you
used to traveling
northern he was like
he's like very snowy at certain points
of the year like it's not as bad as like
seats are a little further north but it
can get pretty bad still
[ __ ] that
it gets cold as [ __ ]
this i can't hear you at all oh yeah i
don't think your mic's on is your mic
not on
a barrier truck in your driveway to the
point that you walk out on top of your
truck
oh after you after you have to crawl out
of your window to get out yeah sometimes
you actually like it would barricade
your door there would be so much snow
like like it would be that high like
it's so crazy
on the freeway rare occasion getting
snowed in on the freeway and die yes
pissed i was so [ __ ] mad as i was
dying
going on the freeway did you see that
like 50 car pileup that happened to
dallas when it got right or like
50 car pile up yeah that'd be crazy if
you could pull up a video of it like
there's like so like you just can't stop
i guess and they're just sliding into
each other wait wait and they're getting
[ __ ] up right yeah yeah yeah they're
getting smashed into and like some
people are running out or like some
people are like into cars
[Music]
i don't i don't like that guy yeah look
at that [ __ ] dude it's crazy
they're just trying to break right there
and they can't even make it no
black eyes oh [ __ ] yeah
that's so brutal that's [ __ ] crazy
how many cars do you say i said a
hundred plus they're like
five people died
[ __ ] up several are trapped
this guy can't get that guy's the worst
scariest [ __ ] ever yeah
it's impossible to stop huh especially
on a highway you can't stop
like where are you gonna go
oh bro a hundred car
that's crazy 100 car pileup dude people
die that's so [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] it if i
can die in the car i should be going
that fast that's so sad that's scary car
accidents are crazy number one cause of
death car actually in some places
i think illinois like i think it's the
only like one of the only states where
like i think overdoses take overtake
like car deaths
heroin addicts out there
approach
houses
like heroin
it's crazy i've been seeing philadelphia
this one street on philadelphia my tick
tock algorithm is [ __ ] we gotta see i
seen that street that you're talking
about you saw that what is it 100 it's
like a street of like 30 dudes just
doing doing the walk trying to stay
awake
trying to fall it's very like popular it
was [ __ ] it's not it's like the it's
like philadelphia skid row or wherever
it was like
everyone's standing trying not to fall
it's like the mannequin challenge
that's so fun
but a whole blocks worth
and everybody just froze the same time
it's so sad it's insane yeah it's
actually crazy yeah it's [ __ ] actually
terrible what a crazy like yeah you
gotta fix that [ __ ] huh what a crazy
like hard thing to fix you gotta just
give a cooler drug that's cheaper
hey you know this drug you get [ __ ] up
by crack except you know it's kind of
healthy oh where's that at oh nice i
smoke some [ __ ] that green crack
oh shout out to the green crack it's one
of my favorite streams green crack when
i was a kid that was like oh you got
some gold green crack is a fire strain
yeah [ __ ] yeah the way it used to grow
though
i mean santa cruz grew a fire just like
the big the big buds of green crackers
so fun they're like christmas they look
like real christmas trees they're
amazing i love it but upside down
yeah i mean the way they grow it looks
awesome bro green crack grows mass but
so does blue dream blue juice trash i've
only had like three good blue dreams in
my life yeah the dream is a very
overrated stream it's just that's how
you say this that was like the name you
heard when you just first started
smoking yeah yeah oh that blue dream bro
you heard in the movies and the songs
yeah yeah he's smoking like a
stranger
ago yesterday was hot 20 years
do you guys have a choice of strains out
there marty in new york or not
no [ __ ] no you're good yeah trash and
worse trash usually
but i was on the low levels of the [ __ ]
too so
yeah
i'm sure there's been so much i'm the
only person yeah people there's always
like that people in new york and they're
like bro i smoke only fire like
you guys all have to struggle to get
weed that's so crazy i've never
experienced that before no way i mean i
have like as a kid i'm saying like
quality wise yeah it's never been like a
thing out here right which is so crazy
we're so lucky bro we're so low i'm so
lucky to be great yes you're blessed
i hear horror stories about texas i'm
always like facebook prison time for
this and this and this i got for some
weed i got homies that are smoking on
some crazy [ __ ] and i'm like bro you
shouldn't be smoking on that like that's
not good like you only got one pair of
spiders you know what i mean well some
people just want to smoke a blunt
right with trash just so they can do
this and the oral fixation of smoking
yeah it's just
repetition you know correct yeah you're
addicted to doing it yeah it's something
you do while you do stuff at home
yeah it's just what you do yeah and some
people are like yo
i'll smoke whatever but it's all good
for sure right yeah i guess it is all
good it's up it's up to the oh my god i
only smoked one
yeah at least my 20. oh that was
supposed to smoke with santa i forgot i
finished this one it's all good uh it's
been 20 [ __ ] minutes i know
that how are you feeling i'm high i'm
not
i'm feeling good
[Music]
until you get it going exactly
all right here we go you guys ready of
course who's that always um i think
goblin's up right now
are you just picked did you just pick
those so it might be i don't think i
picked these oh [ __ ] i might have picked
oh i did it's your turn so is it okay
yes
here we go
picking some stiff
oh [ __ ] oh no i had that in my hand too
oh that looks delicious a nice beverage
we just smoked you know iced tea and
lemonade here we go a little arnold
palmy arnold palmy uncle arnie's what a
name bro
oh good [ __ ] i didn't even notice that
yeah coming up with the canon's name and
like push trees bro it's a dope name
do you get questions about that right
people are like how do i come up with a
brand name or like you know like yeah oh
yeah it's honestly dude
do you it's
it's easy
it depends on what you want like what
your direction yeah what you think what
you're trying to appeal to
that's really what it is and you just
think of does that do you feel goofy as
[ __ ] when you say it do you feel like a
dummy yeah
and like y'all should be that's a huge
thing like the sound appeal or like the
appeal to like yeah yeah yeah these are
[ __ ] child child proof yeah dude i
was trying to squeeze
that out
i'm actually trying to bite it open and
i still can't
this is one of the hardest things i've
ever had to do canvas packaging out here
in california are serious they don't
want none of your kids getting
break man yeah they're not playing
around
in the uh
edit if you want maybe we can cut some
of us just opening packaging if you want
yeah i didn't realize like yo for people
in the car just
asmr packaging and [ __ ] that's us like
crazy man dude this [ __ ] is my
friendship i got i saw somebody find out
what asmr was the other night he's like
a four-year-old dude he's looking at
like
so this girl is just
licking a microphone it's been 10 hours
like yeah but look how much money she
made like
i feel like yeah disgusted almost like
girls make thousands a day for sure oh
crazy
oh nice how the [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] it smells like an otter pop melted
oh
no way oh
wait
oh you [ __ ] smells like some
super sugar but in a way not bad why did
you guys shake i shook it up
i just slapped it in the shakers
you have to hey that's what i'm saying
that yeah it's good shakes i think it's
good
i'm scared i'm scared to shake it
there we go so on the youtube topic real
quick yes
in the end what's your what's the end
goal for doing youtube [ __ ]
i feel like for everybody there should
always be like an exit plan like no
matter what it is like
forever that's fine right right these
are like an end goal like hey man if i
could turn that into this like a show or
this or a travel or something on vice or
something it's like what would be your
end goal of like what you do like start
a [ __ ] gaming team and start making
these fools make money for you and [ __ ]
like what would you be your angle i mean
that i don't know that shit's a little a
little too much i just wanna
um
if you don't have one too that's fine i
just kind of eventually want to make
enough money to move into like
you know starting my own business nice i
feel like yeah yeah that's like like
selling glass that kind of [ __ ] nice of
course stuff yeah right
like weed related of course but
you know just be in the industry somehow
because it's like a big industry it's
gonna be a big industry yeah like it's
gonna be the massive way and i feel like
a lot of people ask what's the easiest
way to like get into the industry
because like a lot of people wanna be
growers or processors or like work in a
dispensary your own dispensary all this
stuff and it's like if you want to just
like force your way in it's like youtube
gets like some good connections honestly
you know what i mean that's true yeah
yeah that's true just like just from
like the because you don't have to move
to cali you don't have to like enjoy
your wedding
events you can do it from illegal states
yeah yeah you just like you just start
recording yourself [ __ ] doing some
[ __ ] you know what i mean something
unique i think a lot of people think
it's like well you're doing this and
you're editing i don't know programs
like [ __ ] i didn't know any of that
right it's all available online too you
can learn whatever it is
i suck at learning especially computers
i told you 100 it's still i still try
and i learn
and it's easy to just like yeah learn a
skill like that like if you just look at
something like just [ __ ] work on it
you'll get good at it you know what i
mean yeah dude
that's exactly that's exactly what
people i get that question every [ __ ]
day right now how do i get into it like
bro just start just record yourself just
like do something do you like it if you
don't like it don't force yourself just
recording right right right there if
there's something you don't like bro
don't do it because other people won't
like it either if you don't like what
you're doing mm-hmm yeah 100 000 it's
like easily visible to the people yeah
you can see it right away you got to do
what you want to do like you can't like
you can get creative with it but like
i don't know i i feel that's most
important whenever you take like brand
deals and stuff you know
like
turn your mic toward this way a little
is it is this still not towards me uh
that way a little because when you turn
it to the right yeah i'm like lose to
your right i keep losing your words do
you hear it too yeah yeah okay okay is
that better
really good yeah all right all right
good okay yeah that's better that's
better okay but um you take brand deals
you said no i said it's a it's kind of
like most
most apparent when like you do brand
deal videos you know like you have to
promote a product you like or else like
it's gonna be obvious that the product
is [ __ ] right 100
yeah yeah that's what i feel like
going back to the other thing we all
promote the same companies because we
know it's [ __ ] good and what's
garbage you know what i mean of course
if not we'd have 170 videos and that's
what i'm saying like i bet you like me
and your inboxes look the same with a
lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] a lot of garbage
it's like we promote all the same
companies for a reason like all the
videos look the same for a reason
because it's like
these are like the ones you know what i
mean and it's like
the commercial where else do you get the
commercial time exactly
right and if you can make a video fun
by the way there was an ad and the whole
thing was an ad you didn't realize but
it was it's not like the whole thing was
in oh we're doing an ad it's more
what did i do with this product by the
way this promotion is me just using it
during this video
that's the whole point and i think a lot
of people don't think it i think it's
like oh you're selling your pa like no
it's not like pay my rent first
suck my dick
and i'll listen to you yeah yeah you
know what i'm saying right 100 but if
you can have fun while doing a video
it's like come on exactly how can you
not like and just like provide like it's
not even like not selling out because
we're providing like some good like i
feel like selling out is like doing
something here's this trash video yeah
exactly yeah selling [ __ ] but it's like
you're not selling that and i feel like
the goals just change a lot around that
too but you're not selling out for
getting a brand deal or getting paid
like remember like bro like 10 years ago
you could take a brand new like oh sell
out immediately like yeah
whatever the [ __ ] but yeah 100 people
like bro [ __ ] you but nowadays it's like
you get comments like get that bag bro
like even if it's a shitty ass some
people post some garbage and people are
like yeah hey get that yeah
bro like you know what i mean do
whatever you need
that bag could be interpreted in so many
bad ways and bad ways
that's what they're saying
so what'd you do when you typed a [ __ ]
what's what'd your face look like right
leave an emoji
i know you're feeling
this is a good way or a bad way yeah
just dude it's hard man it's especially
like i'm saying for you out there you
can't do legal company [ __ ] and legal
companies are the only ones that have
that's a budget change
to do stuff going out here
i was telling him fly out here once a
month for three days film two sick
videos yeah that's what i was doing for
a while then it turned into like two or
three and then i was like yo i'm just
spending so much on flights and airbnb's
like i'd rather just move here okay
you know formula right the formula is
there you should only do it when it like
makes sense you know what i mean but it
already makes sense for you like you
know what i mean yeah a lot of people go
like that's like a tale that's like a
you know what i mean uh what's it called
an age-old dream or whatever the [ __ ]
like moving to l.a when you don't really
have a plan like no everyone knows like
that's not a good plan like you should
already have some [ __ ] up you know what
i mean or whatever you do right you're
100 i mean yeah
i'm working with like a lot of a lot of
companies that are out here i have
worked with but like [ __ ] and will
work with right in the future but i mean
it's just it's very expensive here and
my current situation i'm in my lease uh
for at least another year oh yeah not
right now
you're gonna be out here
you're gonna be out here a hundred
percent [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] you a month
out here man one video a month and that
travel expense it's paid for at that
point right yeah yeah but it's paid for
yeah come out here and
do fun [ __ ]
it's it's it's not more about like oh
cool what company is more about yo what
did i get to do for work
yeah you know i always think about like
the video like title almost like how can
i make this like the dope i think the
video is the title right i try to
surround it with that 100 yeah yeah for
sure
that's the best this is the i don't know
like we're trying to like for the story
times and [ __ ] it's about to be season
four
which is unreal
i'm about to set up a whole story
i know that's [ __ ] and i'm sitting
here like yeah i mean i should have done
seven stories per topic
i could have like season 30 out here
is there a way you like categorize like
what stories you upload or like like
arrange them or do you just like
like uh
coke all right cool and i go like this
all right chapter one first time i here
we go boom and then what's the next
time that's worth talking about because
you've done kind of coke a thousand
times i'm not gonna talk about every
[ __ ] time right absolutely i mean
there's just like certain part or like
getting caught by the cops or getting
away from cops i think of oh yeah that
one time with spencer oh yeah all right
[ __ ] yeah i write down like hey remember
with spencer that one time and you guys
saw the fireworks yeah and then i'm like
okay hold that whole story everybody
know what happened i was there
and that's how it happens but spike
that's the most fun dude i feel people
like when you talk just talk about
yourself like yeah you're you're sitting
there you're a radio yeah you're
essentially without seeing you you're a
radio show host yeah
think about it people connect with you
[ __ ] wolf man
yeah you're like the main yeah
um
[Music]
i think
what's like what's really interesting
about
story videos and i i mean have you ever
uploaded any like yeah yeah yeah yeah i
have a couple of them and they did
really well because i was doing like
since i moved out here it was like hella
just like like action-packed content
like vlog like going to hell events like
review another things like you know what
i mean doing crazy things and then i
just uploaded one recently where i was
just sitting down like talking and like
connecting with the camera a little bit
and people were like really [ __ ] with
it it's like the most connection yeah
exactly the most like interaction i've
done on a video in a minute [ __ ] right
hundred percent we're on live stream
it's like which like yeah yeah it's like
what differentiates you from like the
next [ __ ] that just smokes weed
on can you have a camera on you live and
be like
don't do that you'll be fine right and
if you do do that just keep working on
it yeah yeah the first line skill you
develop and it's like it's really easy
100 not really easy but like
you see have you ever seen one of this
fool's lives like watched more than like
10 minutes it's [ __ ] funny yeah
the rp streams are funny too they feel
like everyone does like oh
they're funny i do rp streams they're
funny they're a grand theft auto role
play you know what that is
it's funny as [ __ ] i didn't know that
say you're a guy the country guy can he
come on
and see you yeah yeah yeah in the game
right right like yo that's my homie
goblin right there
but we don't say goblin we're saying
like oh that's my homie you know
so you just have like this alternate
little like video game like it's funny
because like some funny [ __ ] happens you
can do some
like party make yourself back in buffalo
literally just back and just
doing crazy grand theft auto the
craziest part is like there's people
that role play like the cops and the
medical [ __ ] so you'll get hurt
yeah and they'll arrest you and you'll
be like you're getting arrested for this
and you go to jail you go like to the
court if you just turn around pop them
in the face then you get like you're
gonna go to prison for a minute yeah
you're gonna go to prison like there's a
little jail in there or something or if
you break rpgs there's a lot of rules
like you can't just like mark a cop you
know what i mean so like they'll like
ban you like you can't even play on the
server so there's like [ __ ] kidding
yeah there's like rules rules like you
have to be in like character and
everything yeah yeah you have to like so
it's not the real version of grand theft
auto it's a different version yeah yeah
it's just like online like imagine the
same man
or something right it's the same exact
map but imagine like 140 like people are
like from around the world
what's up man where are you from oh i'm
from germany
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
i'm slipping that sounds super [ __ ]
fun it's
[Music]
uh you go like you literally it's like
rp like life like you get a job or like
you grind you get a weapon license you
get a driver license like you buy a car
like oh hell no no
because along the way because like
that's like the real [ __ ] but then
there's like the the like the legal [ __ ]
the illegal [ __ ] is like you process
meth you gotta find you gotta find the
heroin fields and like find the
and process it and go to a certain place
you can drop it off to certain people
like wait
so you could be
i was a big drug dealer yeah yeah yeah
yeah and you sell drugs right right or
you can sell cars like you'll saw cars
people sell illegal guns because people
don't want to get the weapon license so
you can get like a fine to drugs
buy it re-up right right and then like
in the game you're counting money out
and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you can buy a car with money
you can do everything yeah
i get why people are playing games that
sounds so fun yeah it's funny it is true
though like i i used to play the show i
don't play it anymore but like it's so
fun dude yeah you can actually you can
pretty much do anything you can imagine
that's [ __ ] cool
oh my god that sounds so fun you buy a
house so i can play that right now on my
ps5 not your
computer you need
[Music]
there's like certain servers and so you
gotta like click and download but it's
dope it's worth it it's so good like i
would buy a computer for gta rp alone
for sure yeah for sure it's it's like
that
like you'll spend hours yeah yeah that's
right
i want to try this [ __ ] it's fine bro
that sounds so fun it's hilarious go
work it like like i don't want to do it
yeah yeah and like a homie like it'll be
funny because you'll be playing with
homies and then he'll die in game and
you'll just like that
you know funny ass way if they die in
the game do you respawn uh you gotta get
him to a medical if you want to keep him
all if you want to keep all his like
possessions and [ __ ] because you can
respawn but it takes like a few minutes
but you can take him to a hospital and
then like the little nurses would be
like oh you got a broken leg so what
would get you killed if everybody's
playing by real rules
that's what makes it fun because some
people don't play by the rules like
that's why the cops are there like you
get run over sometimes they're like you
getting gun fights and [ __ ] and you're
like what the [ __ ]
do you have a character you play yeah
ngta roleplay yeah what about him i'm
saying what's his name oh bubba biggs
bubba biggs yeah
what about it yeah who's that your kid
yeah dude that's my my son if you will
bubba biggs is he a racist or is he just
a crazy uh crazy he's just a drunk man i
mean it's like a little redneck huh
what'd you say that's what i'm saying
like is he a cool redneck yeah he's a
cool ready he's a cool redneck for sure
he's a good man you know he's a good man
and he takes care of his kids absolutely
yeah yeah seven kids
seven
all same lady and uh four dead
or are dead
you can't talk about it dude you made
the bio of this man dude you gotta have
the back story bro you gotta have the
backstory
story to tell people about the amount of
kids i have on the game so people always
like i'll be like with a group of people
in the game to be like oh dude like how
are your kids doing and they'll be like
how many kids you have no i'll say a
number and they'll be like what dude
like that's not gonna be said
i'll be like oh you guys listen to me
like
so you're the same guy all the time
what's his job
i don't know it depends on the day dude
he's about to contract [ __ ] does what he
needs
around banks
grocery stores sounds great yeah so you
go to prison and what happens when
you're in prison oh i've been he's gonna
wait times on that [ __ ]
i've been in jail a million times
there's like operation where you getting
like joking oh you're holding me down
you're just walking around in prison
yeah but you can get in prison fights
and like yeah make a shank
gta is really gone and above and beyond
no it's gone way overboard i've never
heard of it
it's a new level you should really want
to try that that's like this shit's
insane
it's a pretty good time for sure it's
funny as [ __ ] there's no like
i guess there is like gaming experiences
like like vr chat and all that where you
go in like a virtual world but it's just
like a different one it's not the same
thing because it like you actually have
things to do yeah yeah 100 100 it's so
crazy yeah
they are chat
vr is so cool yeah
that's crazy remember
the vr [ __ ] i always showed his son oh
my god it's just oh man it's like yeah
my little brother has the valve
something oh my god he's a valve index
yeah i think it's dope i have that thing
too i have that thing too it's fresh as
[ __ ]
i used to have a um htc vive nice nice
that's like that one that like a lot of
people recommend yeah i i ended up
getting rid of it because i just didn't
play enough of the games right i can't
play for long enough for the time you
know yeah
like i for sure nah yeah the index is
lit the index is the only uh so fun the
nx is the only vr one that you can track
your fingers like it tracks your
individual gay it's nuts i played the
game super hot
nice
that's a good one though that's a good
one yeah it's a simple game but it's
dope it's like immersive right even
though it's just like i forget that i'm
in the game man
that's kind of scary though
for sure would you think they have
contacts like that
and start putting him in drunk people's
eyes remember like the google glasses
and the snapchat glasses yes like the
snapchat classes the google glasses they
have those favorites the google ones are
clean the google ones
and it was like a beta and you had to
like i signed up and i didn't get it
they were kind of hard on actually what
would it do for you
it was like almost like a vegeta like it
would like switch down
and it would just like it'd be like a
little info thing on your like glasses
lens like you would like some futuristic
[ __ ] yeah dude but it wasn't like 2012
or something like a really early like
2013 i don't know what that close to my
brain
damn near that sounds scary times
technology's crazy bro worked that
fantastic it's been 20 minutes oof has
it now yeah has it now
oh we're getting there yep oh we're
getting there yep yep yep
oh
[Music]
oh there it is is that a real train it's
a real truck oh i thought that was a
little sound effect
we're not that good oh that's a crazy
train why don't they transport you need
some drugs on there for sure someone's
got in their bag right these are perfect
i mean what kind of drugs are on that
train cocaine pills of any kind
uh
yeah go follow it for sure dark night
dark night rises oh there's only a
couple things left yeah there's only a
few things left let's smoke something
going i knew it the oblonto there's a
good people right here oh blood didn't
you do something with them yeah what did
you do had an eric con blood
is that really what it was yeah i had my
face on it and [ __ ] it was on the on the
the like the yes yeah released in like
hella dispensaries across the country
across the state and [ __ ] cross country
i wish but oh [ __ ] it was lit as [ __ ] it
was awesome they're doing some coil
posts right now shout out to her she's
dope's [ __ ] cool yeah shout out to
obama man they're cool people
that's hella tight yeah two people that
started it my thing and i dropped it
they're cool
oh no way where is he he looked happy
i looked at you like my dog just died
i'm not sure where is it
do you see it marty
it's so hard to move in these chairs
yeah yeah yeah it's pretty impossible
do you have a dope chair do you edit
sitting down or do you stand up
i have a super super super trash
gaming chair i didn't know it was trash
i have a really bad term and then i just
bought one that's been in my house in a
box i haven't put it together
nice like a really nice chair like a d
yeah oh i bought a super like expensive
one okay
or whatever i have no idea bro i've been
hearing about dope shares and i was like
i spent a lot of time sitting down
all [ __ ] day yep just editing and
editing like a really expensive chair
like a stupid shot yeah yeah yeah and we
totally didn't do it oh yeah for sure
let's take a look i feel like at some
point we like said we were going to you
guys feel drunk
i don't know i don't know i'm more high
than drunk but like yeah
i have no idea i don't i've lost count i
don't i mean i never was counting to
begin right right
do you guys go through your comments
ever yeah yeah yeah only for the first
like two or three days because then like
the weird that's hard it's alright
that's so yeah
it's so weird after the first couple
days yeah because like those are gone
yeah yeah and then it's just like
monsters and
[Laughter]
yo
um so i was thinking do you guys ever
recognize the same people in your chats
and the same people oh yeah hundred
percent 100 percent absolutely
yeah yeah for 16 years
right right do you notice the same with
um your customers for push freeze like
it's all right we've had something we
used to write names and before we have a
system you just know we have the same
some of the same names 100 all the time
yeah yeah same people first
it's [ __ ] crazy right it's been like
seven years eight years almost since
people just ordering yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] ridiculous it's so cool
yeah i was one of you like
to have those core like 30 people you
see the same over it oh you see him in
every [ __ ] chat 100 yeah yeah it's
awesome so crazy huh it literally is
crazy but it's so cool like i [ __ ] with
it heavy
[ __ ] yeah here you go you ever done fan
[ __ ] like fan meet up or anything yeah
yeah yeah i did one for the launch of
the uh lentos which was cool
and then um i've done a couple of them
before the first one was like the
craziest one i think that i ever had
what was that
was that like a [ __ ] it was at a
dyspo and then there's only a few people
that can get into this post so it was
probably like 25 people that could get
into the dispo you know what i mean but
you know a lot of the people are like
not underage but between that 18 and 21
area where they can't get into dyspo and
then uh the meetup was at the park for
everyone that was like just not 21. you
know what i mean type thing and then uh
it was like a stupid amount of people it
was like a sea of people and i was like
what the [ __ ] this is like crazy i think
the cops called on us twice and [ __ ]
because like you're just chilling in the
street and i was just like hey we're
just like we're just like chilling at
like this park but it was closed so we
were just chilling out on the outside of
the park just like kind of like
right i think it was an apartment
complex cool what was that like
it was um west hollywood i forgot what
dyspo it was but it was like west
hollywood area
it's so sick yeah it was awesome oh
you're gonna do something like that
right you have to yeah yeah just get
like a like through and hang out get
like a couple weeks like advancing it'll
be like shut down type [ __ ] yeah i know
that's just what kobe is hella hard to
put like right guys
yeah
exactly that can't be exactly [ __ ]
that's what this shit's gonna end too
man yeah i don't know and it's gonna be
like cool to do that [ __ ] again you know
i mean i could everybody smoke their own
individual thing but you always want to
like yo what up yeah
sometimes it's like to imagine the
amount of drugs my subscribers should
probably bring to a fan meetup you know
like yeah that's true
i like i do i do think about that pretty
often i'm like dude one of these guys
would have to bring somebody or like
opening up a p.o box you know people
would send you [ __ ] i'm sorry i can't
even open one you know what i mean
you think they're like smart like oh
yeah send a piece of [ __ ] or something
like
yeah you guys ever catch any of your
impersonator accounts before
uh you're not catching anybody like
caught though
oh you know they're real [ __ ]
name and [ __ ] no it's happened a couple
of times because people like the
companies will email me like yo this guy
did i ever get it where's your stuff
where's your post right or yeah yeah or
they'll be like or they'll be smart
about them they'll be like yo like this
guy just told me to like hit you up and
send the address to greece like are you
in greece right now and i was like wow
and i was like no he sent me like a
screenshot of the email and [ __ ] and i
was like wow they're screaming out here
man
just this guy's just emailing companies
like as me i was like that's just buying
it yeah
but as soon as i mean as soon as it like
gets sent to greece they're like wait a
minute that's not right all day i mean
so
i mean there's only you can get so far
anything yet like
yeah exactly that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying it's crazy
dude i caught one guy once
i got him red [ __ ] handed and so
this dude i had like five different
companies like yo so when's that post
going up like um
hello who are you my name is thomas i've
never talked to you before
you know what i mean
and bro this guy got my email and
changed one letter
so he had one extra letter so people
weren't really looking at it right
he's just gonna do it right now dude
tomorrow there'll be another yolo after
i just said
that
it's crazy dude people do [ __ ] like that
but you always have to like
ch i sure i look at every letter and
every email all the time because shit's
fake right especially from youtube oh
check this out
[Applause]
or your account is hacked like click
here to like get back here yeah it's
like that's just the [ __ ] [ __ ] right
i caught the guy because he was emailing
all these people getting to send
products and they have the address
oh [ __ ] so one of these companies hit me
up i was like this you go no oh okay
because we sent him like a lot of stuff
to do a review
saying it was you he goes by and go do
you happen to have the address
oh yeah here it is and his name well
good [ __ ] yeah google maps company i
like that oh stockton huh
right by where i live from merced damn
no way all right stockton you're close
and i google maps day and i went oh [ __ ]
it's a suburban stockton it's the birds
i was expecting like some because
stockton's
a little bit of a rough affiliate
i was like oh it's about to be some
crazy [ __ ]
and i saw him like what the suburb is
this a kid he's in the verb 100 and i
[ __ ] emailed the email from my email
i go hey man
is this your house
and i google google maps and the picture
and i sent it to him i'm like yo check
it out full name i was like check it out
man
hey is this your house so i heard you've
been doing all this stuff
right and then just the reply was just
like the most un apologetic thing i've
ever seen in my life freaking and i got
i got petty i'm like hey man
i want you to send me a video of you
telling your mom and dad that what
you've been doing
he sent the [ __ ] no way i have it in my
album still that's awesome i would keep
definitely it's kind of sure it's kind
of you could tell he's a little socially
awkward
it was hilarious seeing his face
so that's the face of the little
[ __ ] scam he wasn't the kid he was a
grown man oh no way like a full beard
[ __ ] wow that's fine that's [ __ ] yeah
i have the video i'll show you guys
later i have the video
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry yeah i knew he didn't live
with his mom like and tell your parents
even know how what age he was i'm like i
know you live with your [ __ ] so you
know those packages i've been getting
yeah
so i've been
like so i've been pretending to be
somebody else and i've been like
screenshot from every company you do
this to and i need the full explanation
and every day he would just start
sending me the groups of emails
what was going on
i'm like i need a screenshot of every
single [ __ ] company tell them that i
had nothing to do with this [ __ ]
does it make me look bad that's annoying
yeah 100
that could be anybody but [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you buddy [ __ ] kyle [ __ ] you sir
i do feel bad for the kid he seemed kind
of off
uh let's smoke this happy sometimes this
what the [ __ ]
this little jesus
look at this tip
that's what she said
um
take your shots
oh [ __ ]
all right guys we're closing in on three
[ __ ] hours
no [ __ ] notes no topics good
[ __ ] it's amazing good [ __ ] that's what
we're doing intel nothing in town
oh come back over here
there it is
water chaser man
yeah that water chase i don't know this
is about his mic it's more close that's
horrible i just try to twist the cap off
this and the cap is already oh you ever
heard sometimes i cut my finger like
that once
how when the cap's already off how would
you cut your i just did it so hard dug
my nail i was drunk one of those are
yeah some of those are sharp for like no
reason my own hand i cut one in line wow
yeah plastic bottle they're [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i cut my finger open on
like a
bad right for the environment dog food
when i was in fifth grade
that slice
right here a little triangle scar right
here oh [ __ ]
i are yeah i can't feel [ __ ] in the left
i have like a very little amount of
feeling like right but you can put your
hand like a stove and like did you freak
the [ __ ] out yeah like it can stay way
longer than any of my other fingers
yeah i freaked the [ __ ] out i was
insane you're a kid i was like dying i'm
not gonna lie bro i thought i was dying
it's crazy are you ready
have you heard a major injury like a
broken bone or a torn like i haven't had
a broken bone me neither broken ah no
cash screwdriver
ow
yeah through the kneecap
left kneecap
[Music]
from the top very deep how to get
surgery on the top are straight
like straight in like kind of like
horizontally what happened
oh my god it's a very long and gross
story oh [ __ ] tell us the highlights
yeah give us um screwdriver went into my
knee two times from from who though
twice
it's a long story oh i had to be quick
right god getting stabbed as [ __ ]
someone's sitting next to you i'm
apparently i'm assuming
that's all i'm gonna say yeah yeah
they're sitting next to you because you
can't
it that's all i'm gonna say you can't
say that come on listen listen listen
listen please and i got stabbed twice
someone said your brother
i was drunk okay yeah yep
great start
i have a friend
and he told me
that he knew someone goes to a
screwdriver he what he told me that he
knew someone who got stabbed by a
screwdriver before oh i was like that's
sharp enough [ __ ] yeah
you did yourself yeah oh you did this to
yourself yeah so the person was sitting
next to you yeah sitting with me yeah
sitting right with my my demons
my demons
stabbed yourself twice
well it was the first time i didn't
really realize that it like did the
first one wasn't that bad the second one
was the bad one the first one was
through the cap
uh the second one was through the
cabinet the first one was a little
through your kneecap you went hard
what in the [ __ ] it wasn't like your
bone but like it went kind of like the
cartilage and all the
it's kind of oh it makes me squirm
talking about it yeah 100 that's like
right there that's [ __ ] cool yeah i
still have a couple little circle scars
of like where it went in on my knees
how old were you for this when was it
this was recent bro oh
so hold on it was hanging out of your
leg
no i didn't
okay it wasn't like so deep i was like
oh i can't get it you know oof it's just
even enough to be concerning do you have
a high top pain tolerance
after that i think it's improved a bit
wow interesting um because that was
really bad
for that was that the most pain you've
ever been in
yeah definitely atop the charge i
remember
i i did uh they gave me like this iv
fentanyl oh
i remember i was watching this
commercial for an air fryer
and i was like in my hospital bed and it
was just like superman when i bought the
[ __ ] out of that [ __ ] bro
i was like i was really [ __ ] up all
the infomercials were coming on and i
was really trying to hold myself back i
was like this [ __ ] looks great
fire
oh yeah we should looks good actually
yeah
so you stab yourself through the knee
yeah what am i even here what's in these
things again oh um
that's what they're like that's what i'm
saying they're like very serious about
their like quality over there at oblenta
which is what i like
they're they're sounds like an
experiment to me you just proved that
that [ __ ] isn't your action you have a
lot of money too
i'm losing money yo tweaking you stabbed
yourself i want to have one i have one
it just happened so i was super drunk
i'm talking black out wasted wow did you
remember doing it i hate being like that
honestly
oh gosh
you ever had an injury not like that
damn nah i've never been stabbed shot
nah i was pretty like
good man i've been kidding let's keep it
like that that's what i'm saying right
that's what i'm saying yeah you stab
yourself in the leg that's crazy as [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] crazy man but
yeah i've never broken a bone thankfully
have you broken anything stabbed
somebody
no yeah yeah thankfully right that's no
no you say you stab somebody i haven't
broken a bone typically you could say i
stabbed somebody yes interesting
dad that's because he was super drunk do
you remember
i was really drunk just as big as i was
swearing
wow interesting it hurt
damn that's crazy bro you ever hear that
thing where it's like it's easy
it's as easy to bite someone's finger
off as a carrot like you can bite your
own finger off as hard as you can
like that's how hard it is
that's horrible
and disgusting
jesus christ
i i i i don't think i've ever had that
bad of an injury like that yeah but
either huh thankfully mine isn't really
hitting that hard it's a hard
so this right here the scarf it's sort
of a ninja turtle helicopter toy
my sister playing with it and some
straight freak accident we're just
rolling it on the ground and that [ __ ]
popped up off my foot and split my chin
wide open oh it was pretty [ __ ] funny
so now that i think about it that's
brutal yeah it was tight i got stitches
and i ate ruffles for the first time in
my life
you like raw food flavors that's the
only one of the only chips i [ __ ] with
ever as a kid oh man i really like chips
they're fine i don't know why
really really [ __ ] with chocolate what's
your preferred snack
like
i don't even know what about right now
like fruit or like
oh i feel like all of them taste like
sand or something i feel like one tastes
like [ __ ] pizza ones like
pie squished together
i don't know but it's bomb as [ __ ] you
hitting it yep all right there you go
yeah it takes a couple of draws like the
first two or three you got to really rev
it up 100
there we go but yeah no
no injuries like that bro yeah that's
crazy marty we went this whole time no
topics no nothing
[ __ ] with that that's cool not a single
topic in sight actually not a single
topic right
not even thinking about anything yeah no
i don't i don't know if i've been
thinking much at all at all it's kind of
just been getting high i [ __ ] with this
i've never done this before it's kind of
nice yeah i like it yeah i like it for
sure
[ __ ] yeah
what oh another shot is that what you're
about to say oh
[ __ ] let's get it
oh if we have to wait for a while
because i know you're not gonna drive
yeah or if we want we can get you an
uber and you can come get your car
tomorrow it's up to you that's cool 100
i'm down for whatever
you're staying up
are you i got to fly out at like [ __ ]
8 a.m so i'm staying up all night
so i don't get it doing what though you
know i don't know watching infomercials
and south park would be [ __ ]
marathons what else do a hotel south
park's so good
i've always got south park playing
southwest there's no reason
fantastic
here we go you ever see those owners or
not the owners like the makers trey
parker matt stone uh
[ __ ] do an acid like is it emmys or
oscars or something when they went to
the oscars and in dresses yeah the jlo
dresses you get your cup oh yeah yeah
yeah those fools are [ __ ] great bro i
love that [ __ ]
pewdiepie like the biggest youtuber he
didn't get an episode but they were like
they mentioned him and everything yeah
yeah they're like yeah um i don't parody
him i gotta be honest bro do you guys
watch youtube a lot
someone not really i um actually i don't
watch the really creators i watch like
topics i like going to like these deep
like rabbit holes of like either like
like these internet like mysteries or
like [ __ ] just like random random
just like random people were watching
right before this right
right but i was like i was fans of
people in like middle school in high
school you know what i mean i would keep
up with creators but nowadays it's just
like i know they're there i know they're
making content and everything but like i
really just watched like topics you know
did you watch like
creators back when you were younger oh
100 high school yeah yeah yeah there's a
whole bunch of people yeah bro i met him
that's a good guy you're my friend he
thinks it's some crazy things it's a
crazy videos you met him yeah yeah yeah
he's a cool guy cool guy for sure for
sure
i would love to make from what i know
from what i do yeah there's a lot of
things on him that like i don't know
people say whatever but from what i know
about him he's a cool guy i [ __ ] with
him yeah i never i never really watched
youtuber [ __ ] right right he's a big
flat earther though yeah i didn't even
know about it i didn't even know about
youtube [ __ ] that's really [ __ ] good
nice you're just doing your own thing
and you're just like well cause i was on
instagram right right
you type in guy smokes giant bong
or something i mean when did you start
that like 12 2012 like earlier yeah yeah
like posting content the end of 2012.
nice yeah that's nice nice instagram and
[ __ ] interesting so you didn't really
know of anyone else like what inspired
you to do oh no i saw this page called
wheat instagram 420
and there was like he had 12 000
followers i went 12 000 people watch
week [ __ ] damn oh my [ __ ] god that's
crazy and i know about the cannabis cup
events weed brands i knew about none of
that [ __ ]
even living in cali yeah i was just
trapping the [ __ ] out right and i would
go to the santa cruz patient center or
whatever it was called and buy these
homemade edibles they would sell in
plastic bags there was no jar jarred
anything i was buying
nugs and grams and eights for expensive
as [ __ ] but i was just that's just
because i had my card but i was just
selling pounds and [ __ ] yeah i didn't
know about any of that stuff it didn't
exist at least to me you know what i'm
saying so when i started instagram i
went oh these people posted wheat online
oh my god i got weed
because before it was like yo pam like
yo there's 30 right here you want me to
post a picture yeah and that's why i
started my [ __ ] like i started posting
ah [ __ ] you don't hold all my pounds
nice
because nobody had seen that really like
exposed and i look all nice so like yo
this doesn't make sense
what's going on here and that's how i
started that [ __ ]
but yeah youtube no i made it in 2013
and didn't use it just didn't post it
just didn't use it until like 2018. you
remember what you first posted yeah it
was a waking pic with me rosie uh
for like three years
yeah i started like 2018 probably like
really trying to
it was september like 30th 2018 is like
one of my big videos
like put effort into everything nice
nice
and um
that was the wake and bake
no that was 2013 was the first video
ever posted
he's like that's what we're smoking in
the morning just chilling yeah instagram
didn't have video back then all right
all right so just posting picture clips
of collage
pictures like yo this this smoked we're
all done
you know i mean like yeah
yeah smoking joint
like
that's a fun way to start dude yeah it
was like it was just like stop motion
yeah that's [ __ ] lit dude yeah that's
how it start there's no video there was
no dms i mean you go to video pretty
quickly or like
yeah i did yeah i didn't talk like but
but talking on camera and [ __ ] is like
all youtube i didn't do that until like
2016 17.
uh no probably eight yeah 17 18. talking
on camera is like really tough to get
used to and you've never done it and
it's like i feel like the longer you
wait to do it the harder it gets it's
scarier
audiences like [ __ ] yeah edit yourself
it's really not scary at the end of the
day but like if you have never done it
it's kind of nerve-wracking it's just
like a new little something yeah oh [ __ ]
something you're not used to you think
you're gonna be dark [ __ ] at but hey
everybody's okay at it just yeah talk
just like chew yeah just to either like
pretend it's not there pretend it's
another person
i mean because i haven't really looked
at the video cam at the cameras once
we've been here for three [ __ ] hours
oh it's three hours 20 minutes go uh
who's that i think it's me up yeah yeah
let it let it burn guys we're gonna have
to speed this up
yeah can't do it we can't keep doing any
more 20 minute 20 minute intervals yeah
ready
yes i'm gonna pull out two things right
now
two things i pulled out this joint it
says fire i've had those really nice
chocolate blunt
yeah i don't know what that means either
but i spoke a couple of them and they're
kind of cool i don't think it's a real
um blunt i think it can't be it can't be
and then this
quick z this is actually kind of strong
100 milligram shot hundred milligrams
see i like that it's so small 100
milligrams you know yeah i hate having
like a whole bottle and it's like 50
it's like
yeah
but it's for people that want to like
chill yeah yeah there's different
markets and stuff which is awesome yeah
yeah which is awesome there's like
different markets for different people
like they're for the susan's and the
carrots and then so we did you guys ever
so like you sell weed or anything nah i
never push no yeah somewhat but just to
maintain my habit i didn't really like
that yeah yeah i've never done that like
i just catered to certain people like i
knew like certain dudes that were like
this chef guy i know to like just oh
cool you know i know you want this don't
say anything under 260 is it because
this guy pays i always hire two you're
gonna be like all right all right get
into
chef guy mode ready go what's up man how
you doing yeah
290 or you got the 260 but regularly
they're like
190.
i know i'm like i know this guy was
paying 400 a zip but if i could charge
270
you know what i mean you're not right
anybody if you can like hook them up and
they're stoked yeah and i made twice the
money like yeah i'll take that i just
smoked too much
back in the day to ever make enough to
you know
yeah start really selling seriously like
that
i mean when i was on probation i stubbed
a little bit
just because you know i couldn't smoke
so i figured i'd make some extra money
for when i got off
but
besides that i mean i could never really
maintain selling like that yeah those
are scary i always knew how much i got
arrested and [ __ ] no stuff yeah just not
trying to do it it's not worth it just
to make it you know a couple bucks off
serving a a quad or you know an eighth
or something [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] it oh
just getting that eight dollars an hour
at the yeah eagle trap i don't know i
was like 16. okay
you know what i mean
it's not for everybody bro it's the most
annoying job on the planet because you
have to be you're on call it's available
yeah it's crazy it's like the worst
thing you know what i expected about my
dealers you know what i mean like so i
thought about it [ __ ] answer [ __ ]
money
that's why i said that's like one thing
right come [ __ ] that at all but it sucks
you trapped where you stayed you just
is that where like yeah the number one
rule huh
always i'm super super super legit
though right right oh yeah bad it was
only the same people okay if it ever got
to like 30 40 different people a day
that was only in my apartment and then
it got to like 25 different giant people
yeah but it was
sometime i don't get a number one tip
for a trap or what would it be can we
say that
yeah we could say [ __ ] like that um
here's my number one tip for anybody who
ever sells drugs don't front anybody
anything oh that's such a good one
that's such a good one yeah don't forget
nothing ever it's like a non-drug [ __ ] i
already know that's a [ __ ] great one
like that for sure never friday witness
you know how many [ __ ] i got
right now that are full grown fathers
and men grown men that owe me 15 to
anywhere from 15 to 150 bucks i can name
like 12 you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
some of you [ __ ] work for
government jobs you owe me 15
i don't want it i just want you to know
that i remember i didn't forget bastards
yeah don't front anything anybody doing
anything never front anybody nothing no
matter what unless it's your friend that
you're selling [ __ ] with
like yo yo i didn't get anything can you
give me like a qp i'm gonna sell it
tonight because i have nothing
that's what i would say like right your
friends that you're like a couple hours
yeah it'd be like 12 hours it's cool but
yeah don't front nobody a [ __ ] thing
and then nice you'll always make money
do you have one
do i what do you have a drug dealing
number one tip i mean i don't know i i
think that's yeah because you said you
didn't do it i didn't i didn't do it as
much as you i just kind of sold a little
bit right whatever else i was doing like
if i had some blow i'd sell a little bit
nice that's just a question that's how
it looks you just did just to maintain
you said yeah just like just to maintain
it just kind of you know never rolled
around with a scale type [ __ ] yeah
like well i mean on occasion but like i
mean like you you have your wallet your
keys your scale
so it wasn't like that like you know
on the weekends sometimes you know if i
was really hard on my coke habit i had
to make money you know uh when i first
started doing it i spent more money than
i made so
but you would have spent more if you had
no money you know so you had to sell
some [ __ ]
exactly yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] um yeah
drugs man they get they'll
take all your electronics brutal it's
gonna take all your electronics
yo let's take this [ __ ] shot and then
this weed shot right after are you guys
down for this combo right now
yeah yeah
two shots
let's uh chase uh let me get this water
ready just in case they both taste like
[ __ ]
so they don't yo i just want to say you
guys are keeping up 100 i'm so stoked
yeah yeah and i know some of you guys
like this is normal but i don't mean a
lot of people that do that mm-hmm
so because remember
for years like you guys smoking them
like yo better be [ __ ] rich
most people aren't and i told you i met
you i'm like yo this whole smoke just as
much so i did maybe he even took a
couple more ribs than i did yeah yeah
it's not like yeah it's not real
or like even it's just so weird to like
have a dick vision contest who smokes
more than that yeah thank you so much
it is not good
most people are like yo no oh bong no
i'm good i'm good yeah ah come on man
let's smoke some wheat but it's fine if
they don't but it's rare to find people
that are like
yeah let's let it slide it yeah you guys
were fine with this little every 20
minutes [ __ ] i already [ __ ] knew it
yeah i'm just saying it's not it's very
rare
yeah it's just think about it just your
close personal friends i bet the only
people you can think of
yeah for sure because you're like that
and your friends around you start to be
like that or they influenced you to be
like yo yes for sure like
yeah your product
all right
all right you know what i mean
that's all so thank you guys for
for doing what you do but thank you guys
for [ __ ] doing it over here because
most people don't
yeah and i love it dude i hate being the
only [ __ ] smoking left like left
like
now i feel like a drug addict
is what it is man it's the kush man it
is what it is came here to get stoned
but we've had we had some guests that
don't smoke oh no oh nice nice yeah
that's okay that's cool
how many have you shot in one day like
the most
two to three hours
back to back remember but we didn't
expect them we thought they were both
gonna be an hour and a half they both
turned into three hours damn
that [ __ ] was tied though that's awesome
it's a great deal you guys are ready
let's do it i just cashed that joint
that [ __ ] was great i loved it yes yeah
it's good i smoked this whole damn thing
so far
so sit this hit this guys
first episode ever
no topics
thank you guys this is actually like a
conversation and i hope you right there
in the camera felt like you were sitting
at the end of the table just chilling oh
yeah that's how i always want these to
feel yeah
that's like that's the most
that's the most dope thing for sure
like you're like kind of there you know
i mean like it's a little engaging yeah
yeah like it should be engaging but i'm
saying like usually i'm like all right
introducing a new person to the to the
audience because not everybody right
right
yeah
i have to do that i have to get right
to go so where who is this guy yeah yeah
i never want that comment after you
watch the video like so what does he do
yeah
terrible job then it's like a whole
different thing you guys are in that
thing that's like you guys have both
been on here before yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you guys are bumping on some [ __ ]
actually people have been asking for for
a long time
yeah yeah yeah
but it's cool man like it's cool oh yeah
oh 100 it's awesome
you guys ready take a toast to this
episode let's do it
thank you guys for coming thank you guys
for chilling hanging out
shot and then the shot of the weed stuff
yep one two three
oh lord
wow that's something [ __ ] fierce i
didn't even open this
isn't bad
a little bit late i don't want you guys
[Music]
yeah
oh
oh
[ __ ] poured slow as [ __ ] off
didn't it
what's up
slow as hell yeah
i said that [ __ ] back for forever do
edibles hit y'all different yes 100
percent i feel like they don't hit me
all the time really i feel like
way higher
really yeah what's your like threshold
dose like what do you what do you um
i can take like the two 300 milligrams
like i'd usually do like 200 milligrams
before a flight or something like that
but like 100 gets me [ __ ] up like a
hundred percent like i'll just eat an
edible one yeah
yeah 100 so i'm like yeah i'm feeling
good let's try this yet yeah i've tried
it before but not right now let's get it
the blunt thing yeah yeah it's dope
chocolate blunt i think it's a hemp
i hope so
same i hope it's a [ __ ] brother
yeah oh yeah i smoked lunch primarily oh
really oh interesting
yep
i like that i mean i also like glass but
like in terms of wraps i smoke blunts
over joints
i've never been able to really roll a
proper joint honestly i feel you gotta
watch one of our tutorials it's just
kind of like
it's just kind of like the friends i
grew up with we all roll blunts you know
it's just how it was that's how i grew
up throwing swishers so like it's just
so easy it's a dog
just walked it again
just because they're [ __ ] pretty good
yeah they are on i kind of i was just
looking around like yeah
like a good little shirt
yeah yeah thank you
shout out five huh
big episode
um
i should have brought like
some candies and [ __ ]
okay like a little [ __ ] up
i forgot there wasn't a lot of candy in
that candy jar on the table that would
be
see what i'm saying
that'd be dope that's a good idea yeah
yeah yeah i love that oh the blunt i
forgot
huh you ready
so guys
i've been here for
three hours and 20 minutes now
wow this is your longest episode should
we make this the longest just for like
give them what they want
um the longest we have to hit here
another hour oh
i mean [ __ ] that's a long time
we're almost like out of this like we're
only like 20 40 minutes away one more is
this the last thing
there's one more thing in the bag okay
it's like 21 minutes
yeah there's one more thing in the bag
we got to finish it on speed yeah yeah
we're we're going to finish something
we're going to finish tomorrow so just
be proud that we all finished that much
[ __ ]
it's like a hot one it's a weed
so what you're trying to do or what i've
always
[Music]
angles remember mm-hmm one of the first
things was a podcast i want to have a
segment
just like that but it's kind of hard
because not a lot of people can keep up
right right i mean not a lot of people
but like i guess it's the same with the
hot wings that's like the cool thing
yeah for sure people take a couple bites
out of the wings
yeah like that's like that's like the
cool thing about it yeah you know that's
true
but also we don't want
people [ __ ] freaking out on camera
but sometimes because that would
scare people right to like oh i have to
go on that oh i have to get higher i'm
gonna look like a [ __ ]
then you have some rapper just passing
out having a panic attack or
something have you seen that video it's
like a classic internet video like a
rapper taking a dab and passing it
it's super hot titanium
titanium garbage huge [ __ ] rig he's
bent over it's a it's a crazy puff in
the [ __ ] the season 100
of course you're gonna pass out flat on
your face
like come on bro poor guy dude poor guy
it wasn't his fault the girls should
have known better this was like 2013
when it happened yeah so they were
smoking sugar wax that was that
honeycomb sugar
2013.
well it might have been earlier
people were dabbing pretty sure this
[ __ ] was frozen isn't it crazy to think
that it's almost 10 years ago this is
recording releases recording all right
it's not working everybody yeah we're
all good damn it anyway
he rips this [ __ ] ring
goes
and passes out face first in the f like
that just like that he passes out face
versus the [ __ ] crowd
it's amazing it's terrible it's amazing
it's [ __ ]
i mean did he get back up quickly
no he was asleep like a good 10 15
seconds
oh i thought you were about to say a
minute so i was like oh no he was just
being just
in a coma
did he get brained
no he just coughed too hard that's all
you know when you get that light headed
he just went too overboard yeah and you
know he's on camera he's trying to rip
it because the guy's like you could take
this dab we'll give you this pound and
he goes i'm gonna take this [ __ ]
damn and take this pound of weed
but it wasn't ready for that glob she
gave him like a point eight oh
and he doesn't smoke dabs right right of
course you're gonna pass that's not his
yeah that's some chaos they set him up
for that point
even for people who do take dabs yeah
that's huge that was [ __ ] up they
should have done that to him bro yeah i
had a fan who is uh who's are you pretty
close homies and his family owns like a
little uh restaurant downtown chocolate
about me brandon
here yeah yeah yeah downtown is it uh el
taco dorados or something like that
it's pretty popular but it was like it
was really lit but um he sent me a video
and he was like yo try to take a dab
like you and passed out and it was like
a cctv camera of like him in the
restaurant taking a dab in the back and
then he just like he's like puts his
hand on his leg then and then he just
like
slows over and she's like passes the
[ __ ] out
you guys ever passed out for dab
no
there was no i don't think so no no no
pass out jeez i'm like at the sesh i've
like had the joint in my hand and i'm
just like no honestly
no i've never done it oh it was so high
at that level
it's amazing i was sitting down on a
chair and i hadn't slept in a couple
days and i was so stoned i went to my
friend's house and just smoked halo
blunts
and i stood up
and i just like
went limp bro i just like passed the
[ __ ] out bro i fell right back into my
chair dude that's normal
you see that no dude i literally like
ragdolled dude it was crazy
bro wow
that's crazy yo i thought it went to a
doctor though he's like hey jill i think
you were just
really tired and stoned oh you went to
the doctor
[Music]
wow that's crazy oh i just like
you feeling different you're feeling
different after what like no i wasn't
it's just like you know i i was like
that's ever happened better safe than
sorry like yeah i was like this ever
happened before so i want to you know
i've stayed up for longer than that
before and that didn't happen to me
so i just wanted to make sure i was okay
you know so yeah yeah
i was chilling i passed out my homie
johnny's house off a dab once
a point like a point nine
but it was a fact when rosin started
getting popular oh
and he uh he's like thca it's out when
cali siftko oh
yeah my homie johnny started that
company that's when they first started
like coming out
and um it's what thc thca got popular
right that little christmas strong crazy
but he had this mason jar of it because
he was a co yeah he's a company
and he's talking to rosie right just
like you guys are yeah and his rig's
like 20 bands so i hate holding those
kind of rigs because it's like such a
responsibility so i'm sitting there
super concerned you know what i mean
like you're like babying a rig because
you know that shit's expensive yeah you
have your legs under it just in case it
falls that shit's crazy you don't
understand that kind of people the
amount of money people spend people
spend on rigs right he's that guy
him and him and jake
it was expensive
but
i'm i got the the dab and i cake it in
thc a because i didn't know like how
strong it was and as i'm dabbing halfway
through johnny looks over and goes no no
no no like concerned
because i didn't know how strong it was
so i'm dabbing and he goes all right
you're good i'm capping it and guys i
just passed the [ __ ] out
and they're talking didn't even see it
happen marty i pull one of these
as i'm hitting it
oh and i just opened my eyes to the rig
of my hand
and i gripped it that's the dab dripping
like onto my hand
there's a little left so that it's the
best thing
i just opened my eyes and look you
remember that kid i just don't travel
through time oh
that was me i was like yo i just passed
the [ __ ] out now
and they're like yo for real it's been
four seconds oh my god that was all i
passed out for a split second that's
amazing but this is enough for this
dude
it was crazy
it was tight
it's not really
oh [ __ ]
um guys it's been another 20 minutes
let's knock this out last thing one item
you have um mario we still good
because everything froze over here but
you're good right yeah that's the backup
audio basically frozen okay
guys is this the final item it's the
final item
hey attila remember when you're out
you'll stay and then you got stuck for
like three and a half
all right
all right sorry sorry just in case
oh it's another drink
a bevy here we go here we go
sunset pink lemonade
big lemonade's a [ __ ] bro it's one of
the top drinks out there oh yeah yeah
pink lemonade is important um pink
lemonade's important
i like the way you're including lemonade
i think lemonade is just one of those
think lemonade lemonades it's a movement
it's good yeah it's just one of those
things that's very necessary i like that
all right so for everyone out there that
wanted this episode to happen
i'm glad we made it a week's a week a
century dollars does it say a dollar oh
it says promo oh it's because it's
probably yeah yeah yeah like they have
to charge the dyspo that way right right
legal laws man not in oklahoma though
that's what they called the wild west
wild west
wow wow all right imagine living in that
time
i guess he would live
[Laughter]
i'd be on the railroads and [ __ ]
i wouldn't even be here
i'd just be a country away
wow i guess he'd live
the other railroads
i need mexico best of luck to you
you'd be fine you'd run a bar
slash brothel
cleaning glasses and [ __ ]
oh yeah
oh you already already popped it yeah
already been popping not the bottle oh
it smells bomb
all right pretty damn good nice
tastes like sugar
um that's what a lot of them taste like
i feel like yeah
right it's not bad like i thought it was
gonna
i think that i think you're over you're
over saying uh you give me too much
credit i think you just gave it it's put
this way it's not gross like i expected
good yeah that's pretty damn good for an
edible yeah maybe i should have finished
that i could turn edible
i mean i guess i could drink it
all right here we go we got this blood
got this guys
we made it yeah
hey i always um just a little side note
i was with uh peter the other day from
plug and playing he showed me that video
that i saw for the first time
hey shout out
right we're like yo let's do a video
review and i'll do it with you i'm like
all right that's cool when i first
started really getting into youtube was
like a year and a half ago
and the owner of plunge play the owner
peter
comes over
with his two associate dudes mad cool
and he goes you know what let's do this
video let's do how to spot fake carts so
he went and bought his own fake brand no
no
i got the brand from this foolish
this is a trapper geez he's just a
trapper you know they always carry you
already know these [ __ ] dudes they
get that [ __ ] i knew the dude but i had
to conceal it a little more druggy so i
didn't know like hey what's up man you
know he would chill all the time i had
to make it a little different but i told
him all the time [ __ ] you sell fake
cards you know you talk [ __ ] to your
friends stop somebody hurts you piece of
[ __ ]
but you still my friends they're like
what are you smoking what do you say
yeah but i always talk [ __ ] like [ __ ]
this fool it doesn't matter i've just
never liked carts to begin with i think
that's a necessity when you're on the
road man 100
true places that are too illegal
yeah
yeah but anyway he goes to this he goes
to the suspension buys a bunch of fake
off knock off brand [ __ ]
comes over and we take like three
blinkers four blinkers
and he straight greens out
we're five minutes in the video
greens out greens out greens out starts
getting the spins pale done needs water
juice some type of sugar i mean he gets
[ __ ] up because i've been there dude
i've been there off of a couple cart
blinking but only a couple he doesn't
really take blinkers yeah he's like he
just smokes his pen does his business uh
okay like he's not tell me about the
comments and he's like
the guy got slapped off his own [ __ ]
but good that's a good advertisement she
[ __ ] you up like that's how good it
was yo that's awesome
they're coming out just in case
his associate you're all right you're
his guy
me and him are on camera you're him okay
he is head down
face lips on the table
like that oh so he looks like he's
k-holed almost done gone
gone feeling sick like he's spinning and
i'm having a conversation with his
associate dude
and that's how we started the video up
like so man tell me a little about
plug-and-play so you know man we're out
of uh we're doing that and he starts
telling me more about the brand and he's
not even on camera
and i'm talking to him camera's right
here and i'm like yo you good you good
you good all right you good we have so
many close-ups of him just slumped face
you saw it yeah it's it's almost like is
this real
it's that's awesome very real
it was so [ __ ] up though i felt so bad
for him dude he had to go sit on the
couch like an hour and a half before
they could even leave because he
couldn't stand up to he would throw up
you know when you're spinning like that
because the car doesn't get you
sometimes man bro yeah those guards get
to a different height sometimes people's
their brains oh it's pretty crazy that's
like what most people are smoking first
nowadays yeah that's like
that might be [ __ ]
man
right that's what i'm saying like that's
the first thing you're smoking i mean
like yeah it's not it's crazy it's brand
new it's brand new like no one knows
what's like it's still dope though i
still [ __ ] with this from weed i get
that it's dope right right if that's
where there's good whatever she at least
mix it up not all distill it yeah oh 100
i don't really i don't know if i could
do this
give me that high
really it's a it's it gets like a
different
really it's like a different type of
edible it just doesn't get you as like
it doesn't get you that good feeling it
just gets you high it doesn't get you
yeah it doesn't keep you feeling good
yeah
okay you're not hyped yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're [ __ ] so like you're
foggy you know yeah almost foggy right
you're not almost like that's what it
feels like it doesn't feel like it
doesn't feel natural almost like but i
feel like yes it doesn't feel natural
but it it you it's sweet 100 some [ __ ]
added right right and it's for like a
certain like demographic there's
probably people that need that you know
some people don't smoke the whole car
like us right
at once in a day
you know what i'm saying
okay
so you guys want to take one more shot
before we get out of here
dad
yeah yeah i don't i don't feel that at
all it's so weird man
the liquor
like i feel like i i feel it a bit i
feel like i feel a little bit like a lot
or something i feel like four or five
minutes maybe right when i stand up and
all hit me or something i don't know oh
that's right hey maybe it happens i feel
like the weed yet got me the edibles
yeah i'm high
yeah but i'm not like
i get that i'd be
maybe because we're talking should we
just go when i'm done i'm just like
should we get to that point where he's
like i feel like that's the point let's
get it
yeah like i'm focusing like yo so what's
up
that's probably what it is that's
probably what i'm keeping conversa yeah
so yeah
for real an unscripted ass podcast this
really has no bullet points and i love
it oh yeah
it's like the best way to do this is
really honestly this is truly just a
friend [ __ ] in the garage i like that
that's a good vibe [ __ ] yeah hopefully
we're hanging out with our homies in the
garage right [ __ ] now damn the garage
smoke man you crack it a little bit so
you don't have a box it yep and you know
someone's smoking a stick in there too
sick foxy
[ __ ] outside man oh that's a rat bash
yeah
six in the inside the house is wild to
me yeah
things inside once is fine but
six houses
six in the garage
six in the garage is not as bad but it's
still gross it's so gross because you
can just go outside yeah you take a step
to the right you just
five step yeah
driveway bow smoke outside like why are
you tweaking you know a driveway yeah i
feel like they're all trying to walk out
sorry right now though
it's so brutal yeah as soon as we
started talking about i was like wait
it kind of yeah i kind of just started
feeling a little slow that's funny i'm
eight seconds after i said i'm okay
i'm good [ __ ] up
you drank before you got here too though
right yeah just not much though just uh
so not really an amount that matters
doesn't even matter bro it's just like
one drink yeah
like it was a really strong one though
it wasn't very good like it was like
overwhelming i don't think i've ever
ever heard anybody say something like
that where'd you get did you make it
yourself
okay
nice nice that's nice shout out to
attila good guy good guy man should i
cube it
where's that shirt
how much do you drink not an amount that
matters right
yeah i don't think you know how much of
a gem that was
oh
bro that's a banana you dropped a gem
right now i mean last time you dropped a
jail
oh what do you say last time you
remember
that's the worst what was the worst was
it miami
there's nothing but
sex motels and cocaine
i feel like that's what you said right
but something that made me laugh
definitely one of the things
like a real-life gta server they're not
joking
it's insane bro there was um so
there was like a fake it was like
fireworks or something but everyone
thought it was like a shooting
so like if everyone was out there if
anyone was at the five-year anniversary
for rolling loud then y'all remember
this [ __ ] on the first night but there
was like an evacuation the cops were
there telling everyone to get the [ __ ]
out and everything and as people like
recognized that the cops were like
associated with that and they were busy
with that i looked over to my left and
saw the walmart getting looted and like
people were running out with like tv
[ __ ] and i looked at where right and
there was like four cop cars speeding by
and i looked over and there's like hell
of people running i was like bro it's
just a gta server like this is insane is
it craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
it was just getting crazy dude
yeah really loud
there's a guy in the corner like
screaming about jesus and [ __ ] and he's
like you should repent
that's the only time
there's a bunch of people going crazy
yeah
yeah shut the bad [ __ ]
only not on hollywood boulevard
everybody's with their kids with
bumblebee
[ __ ] superman
hollywood boulevard is [ __ ] insane
it is the mesh of [ __ ] mental illness
and people shopping
but still together post mental illness
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
you wait for this shot
of course let's do it i'm ready listen
i'm always ready to drink some face down
i'm gonna mix it with this one face down
right now i feel like potentially not at
that point ah you dropped gems
i'll drink till i'm face down
yo it's your desktop it's just
screenshots and and uh
that's how we're trying to get in vegas
oh
if you guys can show me stuff i'm down
for that i just i just don't know what
to do go sit [ __ ] face that [ __ ]
magic show
what do i do i don't like the little
rides this camp all right we're gonna
get you into gambling for sure we're
gonna
drink
fun i will go i'm so down i'm so down
got hit by the end of the summer let's
hit it by the end of that all right and
it's over the september yeah it is kind
of over huh [ __ ]
i mean like it doesn't really matter for
me but it's not yeah
summer is over now but that's okay wait
yeah it's your first summer no school
yeah in your life my life
isn't that crazy wow
yeah
i was thinking about that the other day
at times
that's amazing yes every single summer
or in my life after like this summer
ended like i had to go back to school
like this week or next so i was like
damn what a feeling what if that's so
sad if you're staying up late going to
get
no i do not have to get up early oh my
god i know getting up really feels good
though do you get up early [ __ ] no i go
to sleep at like five in the morning
so you're like a night out kind of
person is that when you do all your
editing like night or like you have like
a schedule or like whatever you should
whatever half the time
that's pretty much it yeah marty does
all the editing the cool [ __ ] i just do
like the skeleton like
chop chop chop
all the other [ __ ] okay
yeah um you guys ready for the shot
yeah
marty how long we in
uh i don't know that clock stopped
oh you can't see it but it's recording
still baby cheers 100
okay here we go
that's a crazy one oh
wow
kind of what kind of alcohol was that
for the people
oh tequila man
is
yeah good one i tried this before it's
pretty bomb it really burns you really
it really punches you if it was cold it
gets you into it it does yeah
that's like all liquor oh for the most
part you know yeah
wow you have no idea how long it's been
oh
we're definitely over 3 30.
that's fresh very good show for the
people yeah yeah
i think we did it we did do it i think
we did it i think we're good we're all
[ __ ] up
oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah
all right
for everybody at home
i hope you liked it yeah man you're
looking shit-faced
i just slurred pretty hard so i think
we're all okay i'm not i'm not driving
i know that um
yo if you're sleeping here tell me if
anything scary happens oh [ __ ] no that's
straight as [ __ ] of course i'm not gonna
sleep with you that's awful
that sounds horrible i'm so scared
all right
we'll leave none of the lights
[Music]
oh man ghosts and [ __ ] man you're crazy
you believe in
ghosts i mean kinda yeah they're out
there right i think like they're rare
i don't think everywhere
it goes right all right there he goes
oh you [ __ ] with ghosts
there's ghosts out there
[Laughter]
oh you [ __ ] a ghost
they're dope bro they're crazy things
out there man for sure
you're a [ __ ] fool
you don't believe in ghosts man
yeah come on
somewhat
what do you mean by that i don't know
bro
like people believe that
yeah yeah i feel what you mean you
believe it like whatever
[Music]
you have to die a certain way or
uncertain conditions
i can't hear you
you can't hear me it's like cutting out
do you hear that too
everybody's just talking like sideways
maybe i can't get here
like you're myself i like
oh
okay i mean no i'm just saying i can't
hear it cutting out oh here match my
headphones
i'm sorry maybe this whole time it's
been my [ __ ] headphones
that would be so terrible i hope it is
i hope it is
yeah it was definitely your [ __ ]
headphones we've never done four mics
and four headphones before it's pretty
dope though yeah it's nice it looks like
it worked out it's fantastic
i'm just having a good time out here yes
yeah yeah
dude that's why we're all here hell yeah
yeah
mission accomplished 100 percent [ __ ]
yes is it complete dude hey you guys
later you got it later
there you go amazing i've lost my letter
like at least two three times i know
but
we have more don't trip
yeah i'm a little [ __ ] up damn i found
it every time but we'll find it all
right
mario how you feeling
sure i'm thinking about
editing this goddamn no no
we're gonna give him
it'll be the easiest edit because it'll
be like oh no edit we got to give him a
shot no pop-ups or something
he's been smoking but he's got to drive
so you can't be drinking
that's happy
reasonable yeah you don't got no
distance
um guys i think we accomplished a lot
here we did almost four hours
good [ __ ] yeah this is a fire episode
the first time we ordered two guests
the first time we've ever done two
returning guests wow last time we ever
did no first notes for a [ __ ] guest
also just some just the first everything
you know just the first
first time
yeah also one no yes number one one
everything dude let's go all right so uh
since we can't do glass [ __ ] we could
probably hit that [ __ ] bong
well we got i have hella joints roadster
i forgot to say oh wow plethora
um
but let's get out of here
let's hop off of this everybody looks
i've i saw a couple guys asleep i think
right for a minute for there's a there's
people here too sorry but we didn't
realize he's going to go for so [ __ ]
long no we're out here but this is what
the [ __ ] we want to do
yep guys thank you so much for hanging
out with us guys thank you for hanging
out with me
thank you for flying in
thank you all for hanging out and
sitting through yeah especially if
you've been here this long man thank you
so much for watching this
chat
in this live premiere chat [ __ ]
if you guys are still here thank you so
much
oh yeah yeah i'm a little [ __ ] i could
just started the
yeah
i could feel it like yeah
i got it
to me guys
thank you so much for watching let's get
out of here before you leave where can
everybody find you on youtube and all
your socials uh youtube just named
erican and then there's so much k c
ck both of them see anna k is wrong so
just think that you know just know that
and just know that
and then uh twitter instagram aircon
underscore you know what it is man shout
out to you uh app if you want to buy
sell glass
trade
glasses it's called classics wait that's
something new yeah yeah
dropping
really something new yeah yeah it's not
it's not your brand no it is is it it's
a nova is different but we just started
glass x if you guys want to invite
private uh private little invite for
both you we're just running a little bit
right now glass training buy so trade
class
and uh you know what you mean like a lot
of people ask 100 a lot of people ask
how do you get a bung how do you get
this piece
yeah yeah like where do you get a mother
ship you know what i mean it's like you
get it on glassex baby that's my hat
really classx.com glass x yes good [ __ ]
yes sir starting
and we started starting real soon man if
you want to invite instagram classics.
yeah that's already got it down
good [ __ ]
where'd everybody find you at type in
goblin on youtube i mean that says
enough and twitter right there it is
wait is it different on twitter i mean
if you type your goblin on twitter i'm
pretty high up there okay yeah just
because
somebody might type it in be like oh i
followed
eight followers
i was porn i have something
i mean i have a good amount of followers
almost my favorite pop-up i don't know i
don't really use twitter as much
yeah twitter's twitter's cool though
cause they don't ban you for [ __ ]
nothing
i've seen an unlimited amount of titties
and weed on [ __ ]
it's just kind of like a cool like all
right [ __ ] all this nice guy bob saget
[ __ ] i have to do on instagram
twitter you get all the dick and farting
[ __ ] yeah i actually tweet a tutorial on
like how to cook math or some [ __ ] dude
all right right you can do whatever the
[ __ ]
like if you wanted to tweet that that's
crazy a video of you just like whip it
up you know
a few of you just like whipping up
and twitter you don't [ __ ] with uh
instagram as much huh i still use
instagram it's just goblin on there too
same thing oh the gbln the goblin yeah
just just in case before
make an account we say the wrong thing
and they'll scam somebody for 400
and then they're gonna be like i'm gonna
kill you like who are you
don't worry it'll happen
i've had some ticks
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's the worst
thing ever oh they won't verify us
right one day one day we all had to make
one bad sound yeah yeah yeah you know
are you one of those managers
click or get a check mark yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] enough but
i mean i feel like it's crucial to like
not getting deleted ever again or
something like kevin just that'd be epic
as [ __ ] but i don't think they'll ever
stop they just hate until it's fully
legal you'll never stop and you can do
tag branded tools and tag your new brand
it's a wii company because they're
branded and they're tech
then we can start doing cool [ __ ] yeah
absolutely make it fun again because
right now it's just like yo
check this out on this app where we can
talk about it right that's all instagram
is for now
[ __ ] you [ __ ] instagram all right man
let's get out of here if we start going
to rancho instagram marty thank you for
sitting here the whole time also
switching all these cameras i've seen
you doing the cards
your [ __ ] headphones gave out
we need to beef it up
sony
that's all right that's the way he's
been out here though working [ __ ]
amazing yeah so thank you guys so much
this has been a long ass episode a first
of many first double
double guest
thank you guys so much for watching this
has been the trifecta
of weed smoking oh trifecta everything
try this fist bump give me that
smashed the [ __ ] of the mic i'm so sorry
oh you're good bro
guys uh
yeah i'm [ __ ] up damn
all right so the only thing open is
taco bell
literally i don't know what a problem
with that is literally the only thing
i'm [ __ ] starving so
all right guys thank you so much uh if
you've been here through the whole thing
thank you if you're sitting here smoking
with us the whole time good [ __ ] if you
match the shots jesus christ yeah wow
yeah if you're on a long drive right now
drive safe yeah if you're on a long
drive you should be almost there mm-hmm
that's it
yeah
[ __ ] yeah there's a loop a few times if
not like yo
whatever you're doing thank you so much
guys we're gonna get out of here just
three drunk people just
we're just chilling so i appreciate you
guys being the fourth
so thank you guys so much for hanging
out thank you for watching from eric
goblin marty and i have a dope ass day
guys
thank you
that was great yeah first one ever that
was long as hell that was great yes that
was perfect
[ __ ] yeah
i'm i'm [ __ ] shit-faced now i can
feel like the drink hitting me
[Music]
perfect
[Music]